please take your seats this meeting will
okay good morning everyone and welcome
to the Tuesday February 11th meeting of
the science technology and energy
committee we have a full lineup of
public hearings scheduled for
today before we get to that we will
begin our meeting as usual by asking
everyone to rise and join representative
pledge to the flag of the United States
of America to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
all so this morning we'll be hearing
three bills HB 696 FN exempting
electricity generators from the utility
property tax and including them under
the Statewide education property
tax we'll also hear HB 708 FN directing
the department of energy to begin
planning for the introduction of an
additional overlay area code and after
that we'll hear hcr2 declaring the
development of advanced nuclear energy
technology to be in the best interest of
the State of New Hampshire in the United
States we'll take a lunch break and then
come back in the afternoon for two
bills HB 710 enabling Electric utilities
to own operate and offer Advanced
nuclear resources and HB
764 prohibiting the intentional release
of polluting emissions including cloud
seating weather
modification excessive electromagnetic
radio frequency and microwave radiation
and making penalties for violation of
so Vice chair Doug Thomas is in a
meeting elsewhere this morning and
so I going to turn the gavl over for our
first public hearing to representative
thank you Mr
chair all right we've got several cards
here folks who'd like to speak and we're
starting with the chairman
um welcome chairman Michael
Vose thank you representative McGee and
good morning to the members of the
committee once again for the record
representative Michael Vose representing
the town of eping Rockingham District 5
and I'm here this morning to introduce
House Bill 696
FN exempting electricity generators from
the utility property tax and including
them under the Statewide education
property
tax now you'll note that I didn't read
and relative to Communications Services
tax
revenues because that's actually not
part of the bill that is a mistake from
the office of legislative Services it's
a carryover from the title of a bill
that was submitted to the legislature
last year and for some reason OSS copied
the title even though the bill itself
has nothing to do with con um
Communications Services tax
and we may try to fix it later I'm not
sure be Amendment yeah
yeah okay so now let's talk about the
do in
uh last year we passed we uh took a bill
House Bill
458 that was a duplicate of a bill that
than it tailing that bill what we did is
we
extended we use that bill as a vehicle
to extend a commission that has been
studying the assessing of power
generation for two previous years so we
passed that bill and recommissioned that
commission and it met eight times
between September 3rd and October 20 I
think was the last meeting 16 hours of
meetings to produce a report which was
sent to all of you yesterday by our
committee researcher Davis Allen thank
you Davis for doing that that commission
report contains 40 findings and two
major
recommendations I hope you had a chance
to to look at the
commission's uh report because a lot of
work went into that report
and it's very
comprehensive and basically the
conclusion that the report came to was
that generators of electricity are in
fact just
manufacturers instead of manufacturing
toothpaste or cars or whatever they
manufacture electricity they are not
utilities therefore they shouldn't be
tax and because they are just
manufacturers like any other
manufacturer they should pay the
Statewide education property tax like
any other business taxpayer would pay so
that's what this bill does it
exempts power generators from paying the
utility property tax and requires them
instead to pay the swept
tax pretty simple
concept and as you can see by reading
through the bill it's some pretty
complicated language to make that happen
but it's no more complicated
than stating that a generation facility
whether it's a Hydro Dam or a natural
gas power generation plant or a nuclear
Generation Plant is
simply a manufacturer of electricity it
is not a
utility so what will the impact of this
change have by the way the change will
take effect January 1st of
2027 so it doesn't take effect
immediately what will be the effect of
this change well right now the utility
property tax collects about
12 uh million dollars 12 and a and a
half 12 and 3/4 million dollars from the
power generators in the
state and so and that money goes into
the education trust fund so removing the
power generators or exempting the power
generators from paying that tax will
reduce monies going to the education
trust fund by about 12 and a half
million now currently there is about a a
$100 million surplus in the education
trust
fund and if you read through the fiscal
note and by the way there is a uh
updated fiscal note for this bill the
one that's attached to the bill has a
and our committee researcher handed me a
new one that has a date on it
and this fiscal
note uh states
that education fun trust fund Revenue
will decrease by 5.36 million in fiscal
12.72-ounce at the stat statutorily
required amount of 363
million but the inclusion of property
employed in the generation of
electricity will result in a change to
the overall Statewide equalized
valuation and the swept rate so
basically it's going to turn out to be a
wash that the money that used to go to
the education trust fund from the U upt
from taxing these generators will be be
uh essentially made up by the money that
goes into swept as a
result and this bill has an FN attached
to it so it's likely to go to either
ways and means or finance and there may
be an adjustment made at that time to
the education trust fund uh to raise the
cap from its current $363 million to an
amount that might be $112
million higher than that but I don't
know that for certain and that's for
decide now there are going to be several
other people speaking on this bill
um there is an important provision in
the bill that says that if a pilot
agreement a pilot agreement is a payment
in lie of taxes contract between a
business
and a town or
municipality and the bill says that if
there is an existing pilot in effect at
the time of the passage of this bill or
the time it takes effect which is
January 1st of
2027 then
that pilot will remain in
effect until the contractual end dat of
the pilot or until January 1st of 2020
2031 whichever comes first that's
important to protect existing pilot
agreements that uh as you will hear from
other people currently exist between for
example some of the hydro facilities in
the state and the municipalities in
reside I think that pretty much covers
the substance of the bill i' been happy
to take questions and I'll also point
out that we will hear testimony from
several other people um about the
provisions of the bill the important
provisions of the bills pretty widely
supported there is one organization
however that may object to the bill and
that is uh the municipal
Association because some
assessors
assert uh that in order to know what the
true value of a Our Generation
manufacturer
is the assessors need access to a lot of
proprietary financial
data about the operation of the of the
company now we don't require any other
manufacturer in the state to provide
that kind of information
to uh people who assess their properties
so we don't the authors of this bill the
the myself and the prime sponsors of the
sponsors of the co-sponsors of this bill
don't feel that it's appropriate to
require power generators to reveal
proprietary information and as you will
hear in subsequent T testimony there is
a ton of information economic
information about these power gener
generators that's already
public due to the filings that they must
make to the federal government and to um
state and local governments so that
objection
while it's understandable because the
assessors want to be able to put a
higher price tag on their
um assessment
case it's not necessarily fair to treat
these power gener op ators
differently I should mention that one of
the impetuses behind this
legislation is the disparity between
Department of Revenue assessments for
the utility property tax and Municipal
assessments sometimes they can be
dramatic for example the SE nuclear
power plant Dr assesses the value of
that that plant at about a half a
billion dollars whereas um Municipal
assessors value it it well over a
billion what does that do that prompts
the owners of these power generation
facilities to go to court to litigate
and who pays the cost of the
litigation taxpayers and rate
payers
so by passing this bill
we
remove that Dr assessment from the
equation
because the the power generators will no
longer be subject to that assessment
once they're not paying the utility
property tax that will significantly we
hope uh reduce the amount of litigation
that happens between municipalities and
the owners of these power generation
stations
so that's I think a a good enough
introduction to this legislation and I'd
be happy to answer any
questions I I have a question um in
looking at the language uh on line8 I
believe it is uh once payment of the
State education tax under RSA 63 colon
60 I'm sorry 76 colon 3 is required it
may be included in a payment in Le of
taxes pursuant to a new agreement
reached under RSA 72 colon 74 or it may
be paid in addition to a payment in Le
of taxes if the underlying agreement has
not expired or been reopened and
renegotiated I know you talked about uh
pilot providing those options but I
don't see any language about Pilots here
so I was wondering whether the language
here could be problematic in that it's
it's May or it I mean it it sounds like
it's accommodating for different
situations but
also sounds like they could pay or not
pay so I guess maybe I want some clarity
around that if you have it well I'm
going to defer that question to folks
who are more directly involved with the
whole payment and L of taxes situation
it is mentioned on line nine of the text
that you quoted it says in a payment in
Le of taxes pursuant to Etc but um other
folks I think would be in better in a
better position to answer that question
okay thank you do we have other
questions uh representative
Harrington thank you for taking my
question referring to the fiscal note
dated uh
128 on page two I believe you said that
this was a wash in that the money that's
not collected under the utility property
taxes will be collected under swep but
what I read from this note is this bill
keeps swept at the statutory required
amount of 363 million
and it's goes on to say it will result
in a change in the overall Statewide
equalized valuation and swept rate they
said they can't give us an exact number
but it would be an increase in the
property tax base to to be equalized
would generally increase the Statewide
equalized value which is the Dominator
and the calculator of the Statewide swep
rate and therefore reduces the Statewide
swep rate so I read this to say maybe
I'm wrong that the we're going to lose
um well first year 5.36 million and then
over 12 million out of the utility
property tax and that money is going to
then go into swep but the swep is going
to be capped at 363 million so the rate
of swep will go down so it's it's
lowering the rate but it's not adding
more money into it is that correct that
is correct and when the bill goes to a
second committee I expect that the $363
million cap will get raised okay and
more money will flow into the education
trust fund as a result making for a wash
however there are other people who will
be testifying later who can maybe shed
more light on that and it is covered in
the findings of the commission report
that I referred to earlier followup yeah
the the other question I I am I
understand what you're saying is that
the uh generators are no longer owned by
utility so they shouldn't be subject to
a utility tax they're basically Electric
Manufacturing facilities but we do have
some utility owned generation either we
have B some battery storage and some
solar would they still be considered
under the utility property
tax I believe they would be because they
are as you point out utility owned so
that the property is utility property
thank you would it make sense if you
pursue um an amendment to add that
language that that specificity to this
about uh generation that's owned by
utilities still remaining under the
utility property
certainly representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas thank you um Madam chair um
yesterday we heard uh and thank you for
presenting this and I'm sorry I was late
and didn't hear the whole thing but
yesterday we heard um a bill about um
off-grid Power generators do you see
this as applying to that group of um
generators as
well no two separate things thank
you any other questions representative
Swanson thank you representative McGee
and uh uh thank you Mr chair uh relative
to
uh um the the characterization of the
net effect of this uh I kned on a lot of
doors this past summer and probably the
number one concern was property taxes
and
uh my so I gather being somewhat new to
how the utilities are taxed versus you
know Gathering funds for swept and so
taxpayers are are they currently kind of
paying this tax through their utility
bill and this was be shifted to their
property tax or is there going to be no
owners the swept rate will go down
somewhat according to the fiscal note
that would impact individual local
property taxpayers
chair representative Harrington you
thank you for taking my question just so
I get this straight then uh the utility
sorry the generating facility would be
no longer classified as utility property
so it would be taxed just like
everything else in the municipality
whether it's a manufacturing plant a
house uh a shopping center so it would
be taxed at whatever that rate was now
if you would mention that for example
seab Brook was being assessed at a
billion dollars by the town and a half A
Million by the state a half a billion by
the state so if that would to stay then
the the property taxes that CBR pays
would double because it seems to me as
if because the town is going to set the
assessment is that correct of the value
of the property yes towns set those
assessments yes so we could but the
swept rate the Statewide education
property tax rate is set in
statute so uh it's variable somewhat
variable but right now it's about
a120 per thousand
follow
up so I'm I'm just trying to figure you
trying to the town will set the
assessment which in all likelihood at
least in some cases is going to be
higher than it would be uh set by the
state
so I'm trying to figure out how that's
going to affect the generators then are
they going to pay higher property taxes
and will that the fact that they're not
paying that they're paying in sweat will
that be lower enough to balance those
two out I'm just trying to figure how
the math works if anyone's looked at
that yeah so the way municipalities
assess these power generators today
is the problem they currently assess
these generation
facilities uh for municipal tax purposes
by hiring private assessors and the
values that they typically come up with
are much higher than the values that the
Dr comes up with for utility property
tax
assessments that leads to
lawsuits and one of the ways we believe
that we can get rid of those lawsuits or
at least reduce them is to remove that
tension between these two differing
assessments and one way to do that is to
exempt these facilities from being
assessed by Dr in order to pay the
utility property tax now the swept tax
as I said has a rate and it's set um it
varies a little bit depending on total
valuation but uh it's set and it doesn't
value that much vary that much and it
assessment representative
Kaplan thank you representative McGee
and thank you chairman Vose um you
mentioned that you have some Assurance
from from the fiscal committee that that
swept cap would be raised but can you
elaborate a little bit more on that
Assurance because it seems to me that
that is really the crucial element in
this given the constraints on our educ
our public educational system and and
the the the lack of willingness to to
sort of fund it to to its adequate
amount so what kind of assurance can you
give us on this committee that that
swept rate indeed will be you know
levelized or raised to to an adequate
amount I can give you no assurance all I
can do is say that they will look at
that question and decide what to do they
could raise the uh the cap or they could
say that the existing hundred
million uh Surplus in the education
trust fund will be adequate to cover any
upt shortfall in the education trust
fund I can't give you assurances one way
or the other what what they will
do I'd like to move us along do do you
have another
question I know the chairman has me in
this seat because he has to be somewhere
so I just thought there were other
people that could maybe answer the
question thank you so much thank you Mr
chairman for introducing this bill and I
think we're going to move on we have
quite a few pink cards and we were
supposed to set the second hearing right
now so um the next speaker is patab
bramy who's been working on this for a
really long time and hopefully he can
answer some questions for us as well
nice to see you again Mr abrami thank
you madam chair good being here
yes uh P Bry former State Rep P Bry uh
I've served 12 years here in the house
and all of that time on the Ways and
Means Committee I'm going to give you a
bit of a history of how we got here um
this has to do with assessing of of uh
of utility Properties or regulated
properties I should say back in 2016 and
17 the first to come to bat was was
Telecom the Telecom industry felt that
their their assessments done by the
municipal Assessors for local property
taxes were way off and uh we agreed with
them that you know they would they would
assess One telephone poll in one
Community same height same skirth at
$200 another Community would take the
same poll and and and assess it at
$2,000 so uh in that case we didn't have
a commission but it came to a
subcommittee that I chaired and we came
up with a simple straightforward formula
uh that was was foolproof that couldn't
be tampered with uh that gave guidance
to the uh the local um municipalities uh
assessors how to assess uh those those
assets seeing that the utility
distribution companies meaning electric
water and
gas approached us to say hey we have the
same problem so we uh I said okay the
best way to handling this is let's let's
form a commission on this one and which
we did and again the the major issue was
something that U I think representative
V also talked about was this disparity
in the way the municipalities were
assessing these
properties and um that that commission
did get formed and we had
representatives from all the different
um uh constituencies on that commission
which were similar to the ones that we
have we had on the the one dealing with
this issue and I'll talk about that in a
minute so this was around 2018 and we
formed that
commission and U and the first thing I
said to him everybody in the room and
again all cons constituencies were there
municipalities assant
groups um the um um the the utilities
themselves and the D
Dr and um the first thing I said is
there anybody in this room who doesn't
believe that there's a problem to be
solved
and everybody was quiet there was a
problem to be solved and in the
background we had the Supreme Court of
the Supreme Court of New Hampshire for
40 years saying legislature fix this
problem fix this problem because all as
representative all said it was a a
volumous number of lawsuits every time
assessment was done so again we we
worked at this and we we solved it with
with uh two simple
formulas um and they were foolproof it
couldn't be
manipulated and uh and it was for
electric and gas it was a valuation of
assets of 70 70% original cost and 20
30% net book cost and for water water
was different because of some a lot of
issues I won't get into those details
25% original cost and 75% net cost and
in 2019 that bill passed and it's it's
so so then they was minding my business
and I was approached by the power
generation uh Association of of New
England and they said you know we have
the similar problem assessments
are way out of
control but the other problem they had
as representative all said is that when
the Dr did it for the Statewide property
tax the the the the the Dr assessments
were half of what the uh the the
municipality assessors were assessing at
so again I said okay the best way to do
this let's form a commission again and
again it had the it had the power
generating Community there had the
assessing Community it had the
muncipalities and the Dr were all in the
room
together uh and and again we this was
goes back three years we had a
commission we would the problem we had
with this time was that for
utilities those assets were homogeneous
across towns there wasn't too much
variability in terms of how many you
know this time by the way when you talk
utilities you're talking about electric
poles versus for's telephone polls uh
understand that sometimes they're owned
by both and sometimes one owns it and
one owns it and they just share the
polls but um so the the
the the commission
met the problem was that
um we had heterogeneous uh properties uh
or generators we had the ranged from the
huge nuclear power plant at seab Brook
to the smallest
Dam up up north and there were 59 by the
way there's about 59 power generators of
variating
sizes so we ran out of time we we the
commission uh a second time but that
came out of came out of legislative
service so late that we only had about
uh five meetings worth and at the end of
that meeting uh we still hadn't come up
with a solution because of the the
differing sizes of these plants and it's
very hard to come up with a simple
formula the idea was surfaced that why
don't we why don't we just say that you
know they said we're not we're not
utilities anymore after that the law
changed
when power generators aren't utilities
they are not regulated they are not
regulated um uh utilities anymore so we
should be treated as representative V
said like any other
business so we took up that up again and
those first two commissions I chaired
third commission came last year uh and
our starting point was that that
discussion and uh I was at the time
chairing another commission and we
decided represent a v
um take a whack at this and and each
chair this
uh so we couldn't come up with the stord
so so we again we had all the right
people in the room and we went around
and around and if you you look at the
report you can see all the different
things that we had
discussed um and we did come to a
conclusion that that yes maybe the the
solution is that they aren't really
utilities anymore and that we should
pull them out so that would solve the
problem of the assessing and all the
court cases and all of
that and then and then representative
Vos did mention that the swep tax was
involved in this and all of that and and
I talked about the pilots as well so we
we came to a consensus in this
commission and uh there was really two
things that that were firm
recommendations one that utility should
not be uh I mean the power generary
should not be taxed under the uh utility
property tax and that the pilot should
be honored there were other
recommendations that were not as firm
that it was up to the legislature if
they wanted to take those
up
so so I think the question for this uh
committee is the policy uh I know there
were a lot of questions about about the
math and about the money uh my
understanding is that this is a a two
committee Bill it'll probably be going
to ways and means to be addressing that
I think the big question that in front
of you
is should are the power generators
utilities or
not uh so I I'll leave it at that I know
there are plenty of others who want to
speak on this including people from
power generation people and we have the
Dr here and I would suggest uh that you
hold the questions on U on some of the
math to the de
who who help with the
math thank you honorable Patrick arami
for being here and testifying on this
bill questions for Mr abami
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um this question goes out to you
because you're a former representative
um we heard from the prime sponsor that
the swept rate would go down and it
would impact local property taxes um how
as a former representative can you help
me justify this to any constituents who
are already suffering from astronomical
property taxes again I I I would suggest
the the person who did all the math is
sitting behind us here and uh when when
if the Dr you should ask him to to come
up and and discuss that thank you very
you okay further questions for Mr AB
Robin
seeing none we'll move along thank you
Mr chair and I'll ask next for the
Department of energy to give us their
perspective on this legislation and call
up Megan
[Music]
Stone good morning Miss Stone good to
again good morning Mr chair and members
of the committee um the department is
neutral on this bill as um electric
generators are not uh regulated by the
department uh we have no problem with
the
language that's all I have okay thank
you short and sweet we like it no
questions for Miss Stone next we'll call
up m Molly Connors of the New England
power gener generators
Association Miss Connors was a member of
the commission and contributed
invaluable uh input to the commission's
work and Report thank you good morning
um it's nice to see you all again less
than like 18 hours later um for the
record I'm Molly Connors I'm with the
New England power generators Association
we do represent the non-utility owned
power generating facilities in the
region and in New Hampshire um that
means they own and operate about 4,300
megawatts of power generating capacity
and in New Hampshire that means about um
1,500 employees uh throughout the state
and uh countless Millions paid in state
and local taxes um I don't want to I
will I will try not to be duplic ative
in what people have already said but we
do want to emphasize that our members
are not economically regulated by the
state Public Utility Commission and we
really do view them as manufacturing
facilities they are taking a product and
they are converting it into a commodity
in this case megawatt hours um but right
now they're being charged property taxes
as if they have guaranteed cost recovery
just like their utilities so um this has
turned into a costly inefficient unfair
situation that does contribute to
increased litigation costs for host
communities for the power generators and
for the State of New Hampshire itself
and so um I I just want to share a
little bit about how we got to this
place historically up until the late 90s
and in New Hampshire the late 90s and
the mid 2000s um New Hampshire's
utilities did own the power plants state
law state policy has changed that so
that now they're out from under the
utilities but utilities can take their
property tax and pass that cost directly
onto rate payers and be guaranteed that
they're going to get that cost recovery
my members the power generators do not
have that Financial option instead they
are competing against one another and
against power plants across the region
in order to sell their megawatts into a
market and that's how they recover their
property costs and their property tax
costs and so what we've um what has
what's resulted in this in addition to
everything that's already been touched
on is that the power plants are paying
two different property taxes they're and
because of that they're undergoing two
distinct assessments they go through an
assessment at the municipal level and
they go through an assessment at the
state level done by the Department of
Revenue
Administration um this is in contrast to
every other commercial entity in the
state which only underg goes one point
of assessment and that means that the
power generators when they go through
their assessments if they have to
challenge one they go through two
separate processes they have to go
through if if they want to challenge the
state assessment they need to go through
one process for that which means two
sets of abatements two sets of appeals
and if they need to challenge the
assessment at the local level they have
to go through a separate process for
that and so they're going through two
sets of appeals two sets of abatements
there is no other commercial entity in
the state that undergos this and New
Hampshire is the only state in the
country that subjects new the power
plants to two separate assessments and
all of the administrative burdens that
come with that and this is all because
it is a remnant of tax taxation because
utilities used to own the power plants
and utilities could just recover the
cost directly really tax policy just
needs to be caught up a little bit with
the energy
policy and so the solution in front of
you with 696 is really a consensus based
one and it's been years in the making as
uh representative abami and
representative V already said there is a
commission established three years in a
row that met and in the at the
conclusion of the third year after hours
of testimony and um the the commission
recommended that generators should no
longer pay the utility property tax and
instead pay the Statewide education
property tax that is the tax that every
other commercial entity in the state is
paying as well as every other
residential property owner um doing so
would put generators in the appropriate
appropriate category of every other
commercial Enterprise it takes the
Department of Revenue out of the
business entirely of assessing power
plants and it would keep control of
assessing in the hands of local mun
local
municipalities um and I think as we me
it's um mentioned in the report that um
chairman Vose already shared with you
and mentioned in my testimony power
generators are required to comply with
extensive regul ations and extensive
reporting requirements and so in the
testimony that I I passed out earlier um
there is an addendum at the back this is
information that is also in the report
that the property tax commission went
through but at the very um back of my um
present of my my written testimony you
can see the different types of
information regarding um pricing um
operations um in the wholesale markets
there is extensive information that's
available to the public that um
generators are ultimately responsible
for providing that should be able to
give you a sense of how a given power
plant is doing um and so unlike other
commercial Enterprises power generators
are actually providing tremendous
information tremendous amounts of
information uh to the public regarding
their business operations um that
actually sets them apart for many other
uh many other commercial entities and so
ultimately our bottom line is this bill
is a narrow consensus
Common Sense series of recommendations
and we encourage you to um to to adopt
this because to us this is just a common
sense compromise solution um and I just
I do want to be responsive to a few of
the questions that came up earlier um
regarding representative McGee's
question on the definitions of who um
you asked will utility owned power
generating facilities be able to be
Exempted from this tax um do we need an
amendment the definition that we that we
chose in the bill or that we recommended
um that the it is written in such a way
that utility owned generation would not
be Exempted if utility owns generation
and this is
roughly this is roughly line 22 and 23
of the of the bill second page um the
definitions there that we cite do not
include utilities and so I don't I mean
we can look we're obviously open to
Amendment but I don't think an amendment
is is anticipated because we didn't we
didn't want to you know we didn't want
to include the utility owned generators
because they can include that property
tax rate directly in rates and frankly
there aren't that many power plants in
the state that are directly owned by
utilities I can think of a solar array
owned by one but really the vast
majority of the plants are are living
and dying in the wholesale markets and I
want to also emphasize you know there
were some very understandable and valid
questions regarding impacts to local
local property taxes and one thing that
we were very mindful to do it was one of
the committee recommendations was not
have this change in law take effect
until after the state budget that is
currently under consideration is passed
we didn't want this to be caught up you
know and we want whatever the basically
whatever is applying to every other
business is what we want to apply to our
power plants and so we knew that you
know this could impact the budget in
some way so we purposely said the
effective date should be after this bium
and as you consider this I know that
you're the jurisdictional committee
regarding energy but what you can think
of it is is um it's like a large
business is coming into your town and
what does that mean for your local
property base right now everyone who
pays the the towns that do swept all of
them power plants are not included in in
the in this in the swept right now
they're only included in the utility
property tax so right now when a town um
when they're overall valuation is done
the value of a power plant is not
included in that this change would mean
that the power plants are like any other
business in your community they're part
of the overall valuation when it comes
to the property taxes so I hope that's
responsive and I'm happy to answer any
questions questions from Miss Connor
representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair so in your
testimony on the second page towards the
bottom you make a comment that no
business in New Hampshire is required to
provide sensitive commercial information
to municipalities for the purpose of
property tax assessment and that the
commission went on had an extensive
discussion about practices in
Massachusetts and Maine uh and whether
New Hampshire should be changing its
property tax laws can you elaborate on
what all that extensive discussion
is there is the desire I think an
understandable one when an entity is
trying to come up with a fair market
value of a property because what does an
assessor do when they're assessing your
property what is the fair market value
um I think there is the desire for more
and more and more information because
the more information you have about a
given property presumably the more
accurate your information might be but
there right now in New Hampshire law are
limits to what the government can ask a
private entity what's appropriate and
not appropriate and so the commission
discussed how you balance the desire of
a local government government to have
access to information for the purpose of
Taxation versus the right of a private
entity in a very competitive market
business that have razor th margins and
high stakes that they don't want their
information being shared with local
government that's subject to 91a and we
know the municipalities are often
underst staffed and so they have a lot
of responsibilities we're very
protective of that information and we're
very protective of that maybe being
shared um and so it's very sensitive
information and so on the one hand this
the representative state government
wanted access to information that's
proprietary and on the other hand the
business entities that are being
taxed believe that it is in inherent to
their ability to compete to keep that
information
private
followup is there something unique about
Maine and Massachusetts distinct from
New Hampshire that caused uh a
controversy here well the expertise and
I you know I don't I can speak to power
plants more but there was a lot of
expertise and a variety of different
points of view on that commission and so
some of the assessors in New Hampshire
also do Assessments in other states and
so they say well we in Maine have access
to this information and in Massachusetts
every taxpayer has to give over this
information New Hampshire you know New
Hampshire should follow suit to Maine
and New Hampshire I mean I'm sorry to
Maine and massachusett we have access to
this vation in other states but as was
also pointed out in those other states
every single property taxpayer has to
share that information not just power
plants and so we held that that's a much
larger conversation than what that
commission was asked to look at whether
or not you're going to subject every
business in this state to certain sorts
of information requirements is a very
much larger
conversation thank you thank you
representative Harington has a question
thank you thank you for Tak my question
I'm just I want to make sure I have this
right so let me just walk through what I
think I'm hearing on this so we're
starting out with the utility property
tax for generators of electricity is
going to go away so they will not be
paying 5.36 million into the education
trust fund uh the first year and then
almost 13 million subsequent years
following that so the cap on swept
though would stay in effect so they be
paying the swept rate and since they're
adding more value to to the total
property the swept rate would go down so
the generators would
pay a swept rate instead of the utility
property tax but they'd still pay the
same local property tax so is this new
swept rate going to be lower for the
util utility generators or is it going
to be higher than under the utility
property tax so I um let me uh to be
responsive first off what I think you
caught yourself at the end the utility
property tax is not going away it's
still going to apply to ever source and
Liberty and every other utility it's
just the generators of that um and that
will no longer be applied um I think to
answer your question I think you would
have to do that holding everything equal
annoying statement um because we know
that property valuations change every
year and that state law could change and
so if state law doesn't change then yes
um the we anticipate that local property
rates would go down because the over for
the host communities would probably go
down because the overall value of the of
the property in the community is going
up and so everyone's share of what they
need to pay is going down so
theoretically holding everything equal
assuming there's no other changes in law
um yeah we anticipate that that the rate
would go down follow up follow up but I
I don't want to overpromise I I just I'm
still still trying to get this s you
you're saying two different things there
it seems like separate issues one the
swept rate would probably go down
because you're adding more money to it
and therefore every taxpayer in the town
would save by having a lower swep rate
whether they had anything to do with
power plant or not but you also said
that the overall property tax would go
up so you expect the assessments to go
up when this happens and why would that
be let me this is how I understand
it right now when the utility the
generators are paying the upt m and the
local taxes
right your utility property tax goes
proceeds go into the education trust
fund the overall value of that in a
given year is a billion plus
dollars
separately property taxes are being paid
locally everyone else is every other
business is paying the Statewide
education property tax and that is
administered differently there's a cap
in statute that's been there for many
years 363 million and so um there are in
in Adam's noncore sorry to call you out
Adam but Dr is also here so they might
do a better job at explaining this but
the power plants um I'm sorry the
Statewide education property tax is set
in statute and Dr handles the valuations
and all of the calculations that get
handed down in terms of what the rate
should be for every community and so
when Dr does these calculations the
power plant will be part of those
calculations whereas right now they're
not part of the calculations at
all we do have a pink card here from Dr
so they will be
testifying representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here um the answer to this
question may be in your testimony but I
have finally reached the age where I
can't read these tiny tiny graphs sorry
um can you tell me what is the bottom
line monetarily that we're talking about
the difference um between what they're
paying now and what they would pay after
this bill is passed if this bill is
passed
um the bottom line is the generators
will be taxed like every other
commercial entity in the state and that
the bottom line for their taxes will
depend on what they're assessed at and
then what the tax rate will be and so
we've known here's the challenge there's
such a different um there's such a wide
range in the values that are assessed to
the power plants that it can be very
hard to predict and also state law could
change we know that that's always um an
issue that's hovering over this
legislature is um the issues of school
funding um however we we know that the
local assessments are likely to be
significantly higher than what the state
assessments have been however we also
know that this the rate for swept is
lower than the rate for the upt I have
to say though that and so that I think
that it is
and not a number that we could say
exactly what we do know and what has
been a priority for us is that half of
the administrative burden will go away
and half of the risk of lawsuits will go
away be because the it is especially if
you are a a power plant that owns
multiple properties consider some of our
native hydros they they are in multiple
communities sometimes they cross
different states they have to comply
with information requests from every
single town that they're in plus they
have to do all of the the burden for the
Department of Revenue Administration
then they have to deal with um whether
or not those those are fair the
assessments are fair and so we know at
the very least the administrative burden
will be lessened the tax bill is another
question thank
you further questions representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr conis for being here and
enlightening us as you always do um my
question I I think to follow on uh
representative Wendy Thomas's
question I think what I'm trying to
understand is I agree that it is fair
for you not to be paying the utility
property tax what I what I would like to
know is whether you can tell me the
amount of utility property tax that will
no longer be going into the coffers for
the E the education trust fund so I I
will refer for the most current year I
would refer to the fiscal note for the
year that I prepared when we were doing
the the commission because I also served
on that commission for three years I was
a member officially for one but I
attended every single commission meeting
so we got to know this issue quite well
um in the past give or take the overall
value of the education trust fund is $1
billion sometimes a little more
sometimes a little less but it's been
consistent in that
regard within that you have you know the
business Enterprise tax the business
profits tax all you know the cigarettes
um the the alcohol all of that goes into
the education trust fund within that 1
something billion dollar with all of
those different sources of revenue the
utility property tax was again give or
take $40
million and of that the util the
generator portion is somewhere around
$10 million so the overall impact to the
education trust fund would be less than
1% thank you that's really helpful
yeah further
questions seeing none want to thank you
Miss honors very good testimony and ask
now the Dr and Adam denore to come speak
with us because we know that Adam's
going to help us clear up some of these
questions about the numbers and the math
thank you for being here Adam Adam was
also a member of the commission I was my
name is Adam denor I'm the assistant
director of the municipal and property
division at the Department of Revenue
Administration uh we don't have a
position on this legislation but I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
may
have questions for Mr denan cor
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here um so uh
obviously the the the policy pieces of
the bill in terms of whether or not
these generators should continue paying
as though they are the regulated
utilities I think is clear amongst us
all the on the money piece um we also
have as a
legislature the other problem which
which is that we've been told we need to
have more money for education and seeing
the education trust fund go down
um
is it would be of concern so can I ask
you what how the department is is um
looking at what's coming
in
uh or changes to what's coming in uh in
terms of how we're going to be paying
the bills that we have in terms of
obligations around education um I
because I think the education trust fund
if the if the education trust fund goes
down then property taxpayers are going
to pick up an additional um piece is
that
correct I don't know that that's
necessarily true I think that the
complicated part of this is the way that
swept interacts with adequacy in upt and
I and I can't really dip into the
adequacy part of it because I'm not from
education I don't know enough um but in
terms of uh upt and swept I think has
been mentioned a couple of times by
expanding the swept tax base in this way
you do ultimately reduce the swept rate
which means that pretty much every other
property taxpayer in the state pays a
little bit less in tax because there are
a few new big property taxpayers on the
Block um in terms of the way that you
know the the reduction in Revenue I
think the fiscal note notes 5.36 million
in the first year that reduction how
that ends up coming out through adequacy
is difficult for me to speak to just
because of the the mechanism involved
and Dr doesn't really get into that
necessarily but there is certainly a
reduction on the upt side um but there's
an increase or I should say increase in
the tax base on the swep side so does
that balance itself out it's hard to say
without knowing the adequacy part of it
well enough to speak to
it yes followup yes so the followup
would be um one thing that I know
there's a a new fiscal note that we've
all looked at but uh my question would
be then
around uh the cap uh that's currently on
the swept portion um would it be true
that that cap would have to be increased
in order for us to um accommodate the
new funding that would be coming in
from uh property tax assessments that
would be on these generating
facilities as I understand
swept revenue is considered a it is
considered ETF Revenue so then we
discussed this in um as part of the
commission whether or not there needed
to be a balance on the other side by
increasing the swept cap um I would
expect that that would have a on on
effect additional questions
representative
Harrington thank you chairman thank you
for taking my question I'm just uh
trying to get again make sure we got
this straight so we're going to reduce
the uh education trust fund uh
contributions because the utility the
generators are no longer classified as
utilities so they don't pay the utility
property tax they are going to be
spaying spending money sending that
money into the swept and that will
increase the property size base of swep
so it would lower the swept rate
provided that cap stays in place for all
property taxpayers across the state is
that correct that's correct okay and
follow up follow up so I think what it
comes down to then
is we that swept rate is going to be
applied against the assessed value of
the power plant as set by the local
Authority is that correct that's right
okay so okay one assessment only thank
you yep just one single
assessment okay additional
questions representative m thank you Mr
chairman and um this is just sort of an
afterthought because you guys do
assessing around this stuff and the
conversation that came up around um the
requests for additional information
potentially from municipalities on
generators that is not like any other
business or
manufacturer um and can you illuminate
for us what kind of information that
would be because I would think a
property tax assessment I know ours is
based on the valuation of the property
and not related to the success of the
business so I I wanted to just try and
understand what it is the additional
information would be that would be
requested from these folks so that we
can be clear you know how we're
implementing this sure um depending on
the type of property in this case um
let's just say a dam for example it's
difficult to separate the um incom
producing ability of that property from
its ultimate value so with a residential
home that really doesn't apply at all um
even if you're talking about something
that you could possibly list on Airbnb
that that doesn't really begin to enter
into the discussion about the market
value of the property where where the
dam for example its sole purpose is to
generate electricity and produce money
for its owner um so in those cases it is
appropriate to review the capacity of
that um property to generate income
because that's directly going to be how
it's marketed if it were sold um so that
case you would need some information to
assist you as you developed an appraisal
on that on that basis and followup
followup do you agree with Miss Connor's
that there is um adequate uh public
information currently on the businesses
and the uh generation capabilities of
these properties in the public
domain that's difficult for me to say we
have the advantage of receiving all of
the non-public information um in order
to produce our assessment um but I I so
I can't say that I've reviewed what's
available publicly other than just the
discussion with the Comm that's fair
thank
you representative Harrington yeah just
just a follow up on what was just stated
there you you were saying that in in
case of a dam
it's uh the value of its product is so
uh important to the price of its if it
was be sold but how does that differ
let's just say we have two restaurants
in a town and one seems used to be doing
very very busy because there's always
cars in the parking lot and the other
one very not very busy but they have the
same basic uh footprint the pretty much
the same location uh so if someone is
assessing the values of those products
would they go in and say well this
restaurant makes a lot of seems like
it's making a lot of money I don't know
for a fact because I can't review the
books but I see all those cars in the
parking lot so we're going to charge
we're going to assess them higher than
the one over here whose parking lot's
mostly empty is that the way it's done
it it may not be a appropriate to use
what they would call the income approach
to value in in the case of a restaurant
I we're talking probably about the
underlying real estate what the what it
would be worth to rent that um if it if
it was a case where you know uh one
restaurant was positioned on the corner
of two busy streets and that caused
increased traffic you can expect that
the owner of the property would charge
more in rent that but that would have
less to do the with the quality
operation of the business than with the
value of the underlying real estate
followup followup it would seem to me
that that same logic would apply then to
a generator as well uh because if you
don't if you you're not saying how much
they make counts it's location location
location if you will and um the you're
talking about the two restaurants let's
just say they were in similar locations
obviously if one is right off the exit
of an interstate and the other one's on
a dirt road five miles out in the
country that's going to have a direct
value on a direct impact on their value
but how much they actually sell the
accessor wouldn't even wouldn't be aware
of they he has no access to their books
does he not not at the not at the moment
no no and it's a fair point I I think
that ultimately what it comes down to is
is is that structure that the
restaurant's operating out of capable of
being used for other things and in the
case of a dam or something like that
it's like I said it's more difficult to
separate the operation of that business
considering you know you don't want to
no one's going to live in the dam um you
know the only reason why it would ever
exist is for the purpose of generating
electricity and and you know creating
capital and one quick followup okay okay
um you had said that U you have access
to certain uh sensitive nonpublic
information that's when uh your agency
was you're determining the value for the
property uh for the purpose of the
utility property tax so you have
accessed to information that the local
assessor doesn't and now we're going to
go to a situation where the only one
setting the assessment is going to be
the local assessor without access to
this additional information do you think
that constitutes problem and maybe in
the case of electric generating
facilities that the Dr should still be
setting the value and then giving that
to the town and saying this is what you
can charge on because you have prived so
much more information so right now we
produce a um we'll produce we actually
publicly make our appraisals publicly
available and in cases where a generator
is let's say uh plac in in one
individual municipality will actually
report out what our value on that
generator is and municipalities have the
opportunity to use our value now um most
elect not to excuse me I don't want to
be pay in the neck here Mr chair but
just one quick followup but you're
saying under this bill if it passes you
will no longer be doing that assessment
correct yeah that's correct at at the
current moment most municipalities
choose not to use our assessments they
have the opportunity to right now and
to representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in I mean that representative
harington's question does lead to the
obvious next question which is the you
know do how can we be assured that the
risk of litigation will be lowered and
that the administrative cost will be
lowered for these generators if every
municipalities is doing it in a
different way and they're not choosing
as you said to use your your
appraisals yeah that's a good question
um like I said at this moment they're
they are actively electing to go that
way to go away from just using our
appraisal our appraisal is free um and
instead they elect to hire an expert to
do it um I would say that one one thing
that is a fact is that in the past our
appraisal has been used directly against
the municipal appraisal to spawn an
appeal so in that particular case um we
wouldn't have a taxpayer using the two
appraisals to create litigation I think
that's one of the things we're that this
bill intends to
resolve represent un native follow up
yeah I mean just just a quick quick
point I mean I'm not I'm not sure you
can really answer this but okay I take
your point about not having the two
appraisals which might lead to
litigation but how how how we how can
our municipalities be assured that
they're receiving value for uh you know
that they're actually getting adequate
information in order to make their
assessments uh that's a good question I
I would whoever they're intending to
contract with to perform the work um
should certainly give them an idea of
how they plan to accomplish the ask and
whether or not they have the information
necessary and if they don't they you
know they shouldn't take the assignment
but at the current moment I don't think
that municipalities have a difficult
time finding someone to to produce
appraisals I would suggest to all
members of the
committee that your curiosity about this
question can be satisfied by reading the
40 to 50 pages of material accumulated
in the commission
report the findings and the minutes of
every single one of our meetings is part
of that
report you can read the minutes and see
the discussions that we had that sort of
mirror the questions I'm hearing here
we've already asked those questions and
answered them all that information is in
the
report that's why I sent it had it sent
to each of you yesterday so that you
would see this this information has
already been discussed and these
questions have
been answered to at least the
commission's satisfaction representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh I'm sorry I came in late um but I
just want to make sure I understand what
the impact on the education trust fund
is going to be uh we see that the
revenue will decrease because of less
going into the upt and swept at this
point as being kept at the same amount
does that mean that the uh the income
into the education trust fund is
actually going to be decreasing so I I
believe they'll that's correct um and I
think that as Molly has just said it was
ETF once again that subject is covered
extensively in the commission report the
Department of Education who was not here
this morning to testify was member of
the um attended a couple of the
commission meetings and answered
questions about the effect on the
education trust fund by this change
and without having the report right in
front of me as I recall the Department
of Education indicated that the impact
was minimal on the education trust fund
additional
questions all right seeing none let's
bring up mateline Mano next from the
hydro Granite State hydrop power ass
Association M Mano also was a member of
this commission
you microphone sorry I didn't know it
was turned off uh thank you Mr chairman
I'm M Mino representing the grand State
hydrop Power Association and I
represented gsh on the study commission
for the past three years um as this is
the product of the study commission we
support this bill um gsha is
complimentary to NEPA where they
represent the larger uh
generators we represent smaller hydr
power producers many of our members use
Pilots payment in lie of taxes and we
appreciate that this bill specifically
includes language to transition existing
pilot agreements so that there's not a
significant change in the middle of a
pilot agreement pilot Agreements are a
contract between the taxpayer and the
municipality um and so when those
agreements were entered into
the generator may have been paying the
utility property tax and not the swept
so we didn't want to upend existing
agreements so we appreciate that they um
is a transition as well as the specific
language on lines 11 to 15 which allows
the municipality that have entered into
pilot agreements with a generator to use
a value calculated from those pilot
payments by the Dr to determine the
amount of swept to be that is owed which
would avoid having to do an assessment
just specifically for that swept part
payment um representative McGee you
asked about the fact that the there's
language in here saying the swept may be
included in a pilot or paid in addition
to a pilot payment that's because Pilots
are structured in all different ways and
so we wanted to give that flexibility to
the taxpayer and the municipality to
negotiate those new pilots in a way that
made sense to both of them so the the
taxpayer could pay a pilot payment and
the municipality takes the swept out of
that payment and transfers that or the
taxpayer could make a pilot payment and
then separately make the swept payment
to the municipality because of how the
pilot is structured it may make sense to
have one whole amount and then take the
swept out or it may make sense to pay
the pilot and then have the swept
assessed separately so we just wanted to
make sure that that flexibility was
still there for the municipalities and
the taxpayers negotiating Pilots
um as has been mentioned before if there
is any request to add uh reporting
requirements we would oppose that um
that was extensively discussed by the
study commission and there was no
agreement among the commission members
so um our position is that if other
businesses are not having to open their
books to assessors um we shouldn't have
to
either um there's been a lot of
questions as to what's going to be the
effect on us as taxpayers and taxpayers
in general so I'll try and just say
quickly for generators as taxpayers
switching from the upt to paying the
swept the rate is much lower but as a
rule the local assessment is much higher
so how that's going to play out for
individual generator taxpayers is a
little bit hard to say but it's not
going to be a massive change because
you're paying a lower rate on a higher
value so it's going to be probably
somewhat similar but for individual ual
generator taxpayer it might be a little
bit more it might be a little bit less
and then as far as taxpayers as a whole
if you don't change the total amount of
swept raised it's going to lower the
swept rate that all taxpayers pay so
it's going to be a little bit less taxes
for everybody else um and I do want to
just put out there that there's a
similar Senate Bill uh Senate Bill
277 which is sponsored by Senator Lang
and so at some point there's going to
have to be a a Reconciliation of these
two bills which are effectively trying
to achieve the same goal I'm happy to
take any questions questions for M
Mano representative Wendy Thomas thank
you I'm just verifying the name of the
uh Senate Bill 277 thank you
yes Senator Lang was on the commission
as
well it was a big commission it was a
big commission uh representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here uh this question probably
applies to everybody but uh
uh in
nashwa assessments occur every two three
four five
years uh and uh so it I'm wondering it
feels like there would be a lag between
when you know perhaps uh the communities
nearby uh your installations this might
apply to the other producers will there
be a lag between when this goes into
effect and when a new assessment might
be made and the cor lary to that
question is during that interum will be
that there a net Improvement of your
bottom line due to having gotten rid of
this tax for that
interim um as I mentioned many of our
facilities use payment in Le of taxes
and so that's a negotiated amount so
some of the municipalities have a value
on the books and some do not and so
that's why we wanted to have the option
to have the municipality use an inferred
value based on pilot payments so that's
an option for the
municipality um as far as the frequency
of assessment that's up to the host
municipality I don't think that the
taxpayer has any control over that
um yeah so well but the uh followup
followup uh the the question at hand is
Will in the interim will there be an
immediate Improvement to your bottom
line I don't I don't think so because
that Municipal assessment tends to be
much higher than the dr's assessment
that's what the study commission found
we looked at the Dr assessment and the
ms1 assessment for all of the generating
facilities and you know sometimes it's
as much as as double and so no I don't I
don't I guess I I'm not totally
understanding your question as far as
the frequency of the municipal
assessment and a change in in our bottom
line as I said when you're changing from
paying the utility property tax based on
a Dr value at a set rate of 660 per
thousand and now you're going to be
paying the swept on a municipal value
which tends to be much higher but the
swept has a lower rate it's going to not
be a a massive tax break if that's what
you're thinking thank you
thank you chair I I'll try to be brief
um knowing this is going to be uh
probably uh need to be reconciled with
Senate Bill there were several
recommendations made at the end of the
report that uh chair V submitted um
could you see those recommendations
being addressed at that time or do you
see a more urgency for some of those
recommendations uh do I need to go over
them no several of the the
recommendations to be considered were
things that the commission could not
agree on and so the specific I think
this bill is an outcome of what was
unanimously agreed upon by the
commission members a lot of things that
said well you know you may want to
consider these things were were put in
as considerations because the commission
members could not generally agree on
them and so I I would have I think I
would have to look at specific
considerations to tell you whether or
not I think they should be considered or
not but for example reporting
requirements are something we would not
support adding which I believe was was
considerations okay seeing no further
questions we'll give the last word on
this legislation to Brody dues who is
representing the New Hampshire Municipal
Association first of all let's say
congratulations on your new position
thank you representative I appreciate
welome to Chairman and um thank you to
the committee for taking my testimony I
did write to you some testimony last
night tonight I've been Fielding a many
calls from Municipal assessors over the
last uh few days with concern over this
legislation we are neutral the municipal
Association so let me be clear we're not
in opposition we are here to provide
some education and to raise some of our
concerns and our concerns is about the
lack of reporting requirements and um
it's for the same kind of Reason not the
same reason it's for some of the reasons
in the testimony you heard from Adam
from Dr where it's difficult to separate
incom producing property um from the
value that impacts its fair market value
especially with generators and so part
of the reason why at least from what
we've been told by our assessors that
there can be a disparity in what Dr is
assessing these um generator properties
and what the municipality is is because
the municipality has much less
information to make an accurate
assessment and the assessors would just
like the same information that goes to
the Department of Revenue Administration
collected by a government entity to also
go to the municipal assessors
even they think it's more than fair to
make it so they have to abide by the
same confidentiality requirements of
Dr is more than reasonable to them and
also the fact that um also the fact that
Dr is collecting this information shows
it's not really an intrusion it's just
so they can make an accurate assessment
of the generating property um there are
a few other things that you know I heard
that was discussed today that some of
the assessors wanted me to raise one is
that we would be be treating generators
differently whether or not they'd be
owned by utilities despite that very
similar generator facilities that are
both attached to the transmission
Network would be one would be subject to
upt and one wouldn't be so I want to
flag that that that's something that
some of the assessors mentioned where
they said well you have a solar field
that's not owned by a utility company
but you have one that's only own you
know that that is owned by utility
company you're going to be essentially
taxing them at different rates um I also
want to point out the swept tax rate
right now is only about A123 a124 per
th000 of valuation utilities property
tax is 660 so even if somehow the
municipal assessment is double what dr's
assessment is the tax rate still six I
mean you're still paying significantly
less
um so the so those are kinds of the
things that I want to mention is that
you know there would be less revenue for
public education that's not something we
have a stance on at the municipal
Association um the assessments would be
you know different the municipal is
different than Dr but a big reason for
that is because there's a lack of
reporting to the local Municipal
assessors and so in section three of the
bill where there's this reporting
requirement lines 22 through 26 to Dr
all the assessors want from all this
commission all the things that they
wanted to have addressed to limit
lawsuits though a lot of those things
didn't get include in this bill but they
really think to prevent lawsuits and to
help them do their jobs and their
Municipal assessing to make sure that
there's an accurate assessment fair to
the generator property owner um who's
not a utility company and fair to the
municipalities to limit lawsuits is to
make it so then that information is not
just shared with the Dr assessors but
shared with the municipal assessors and
that's the biggest thing that will
prevent lawsuits otherwise you're you
know the assessors are still going to be
trying their best to assess based on the
publicly available information they have
and um the generators if they disagree
with that will still appeal or go to
court over it unless get that same
information to get an idea of some of
this um you know the the income from
producing um sorry the the income
producing property from the value of the
fair market value um it's going to be
difficult for municipal assessors to do
their job accurately and that's what
they raised during the commission report
and um as it's kind of been alluded to
other states are doing this and I really
want to thank representative Harrington
and Kaplan for essentially encapsulating
what my testimony would be just by
asking I think what were the clearly
obvious questions with some of the
issues with not reporting this
information um so there can be accurate
assessments on on the municipal level
and I'll take any questions thank you so
much uh any have any
questions uh representative
McGee thank you Mr Vice chairman nice to
see you again The Honorable Ro Dees um
my question is around in your testimony
you alluded to the fact that the Dr a
assessors um are able to secure
information that the municipal associate
the municipal assessors do not currently
but you sort of threw in there that they
are bound by the same rules in terms of
the security of that information and I
think that that seems to be a really big
issue or sticking point for folks right
is that they don't want their business
information to be made public so my
question would be if a municipal uh
assessor is then give granted uh
access uh do they share that information
with the municipality or they or do they
simply use the data that they're privy
to in order to formulate the assessment
to my knowledge it's the latter um and
there are they I mean assessors every
day are handling as I mentioned in my
written testimony by email that I sent
last night they are handling
confidential information every single
day and they know how to handle that
information what is and what isn't
subject to 90 a so I I really want to
stress that these assessors only want to
see this information so then they can
create an accurate assessment and it's
not information that they want to share
with the general public and that they
have any interest in sharing with the
general public I mean I don't know
exactly what goes through their license
Shar and certification requirements
because they also have to um get
licensed and certification but I would
imagine some of it has to do with how
they collect information data and how
they keep that confidential and
organized okay the thank you the people
behind you are buzzing so well yeah I
was buzzing too
questions seeing none I want to thank
you for whoops representative
blog thank you I waited if there was
someone
else uh honorable do thank you for
taking my
question this point is sticking my
head if you could if you could have an
answer for me appreciate
it the ER has this
information their assessment is
lower pwns assessors and some of them
are Town's people also Selectmen or
whatever they're going to get this the
same
information and I'm um want to wager a
bet they will not assess it lower the
question
is will they use the information they
get or rephrase that how can they use
the information they
it I don't know how Dr does their
assessments I called the line and the
individual who it says call to ask about
the utility property tax and they said
to call a gentleman named Chris and when
I called that number I didn't get a
response so I'm not sure how Dr does
their assessment for utility properties
I don't know the minutia of how local
assessors do that too so I will be
honest about that but local assessors
have shared with us several at least in
the last week that having this
additional information and understanding
um you know how the property generates
electricity how much and some of the um
some of the other uh things regarding um
you know income does help them create an
accurate assessment at least based on
how they're trained and certified and
licensed by the state of New Hampshire
so that is their stance again we're
neutral on it but we had so many complt
compl that um we weren't even going to
testify we didn't have a stance on this
bill and then you know we decided we
should come forward and support our
assessors and say just a simple
reporting requirement that the
information that's going to be required
to be reported under section three of
this bill it going to Municipal
assessors will be helpful not just in
preventing future lawsuits between
municipalities and generators and saving
the rate payers and taxpayers money but
also ensuring that there is an accurate
assessment um we have no stance on how
the state raises its funds for public
education that doesn't impact Municipal
budgets it impact school district
budgets in the state's budget so I want
to be clear on that too we primarily
only care about that reporting
requirement and if there's going to be a
reporting requirement on this
information at Dr we think at least
based on what we've been told by our
Municipal assessors that there is a
great benefit to the municipalities and
their taxpayers to make sure the
assessors also get that
information the commission discussed
this question extensively m
the Dr uses a a form I believe it's the
form
A9
um maybe it's a different number but
anyway the Dr uses a form to collect
this information that's how they do
their assessments and
um we discuss that
extensively within the commission it's
all in the findings and in the minutes
of our meetings if you want to learn
more about that
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you for taking my
question so my question would be around
some of the prior testimony that we
heard regarding whether or not there are
any other businesses for which Municipal
assessors require this kind of
information or if it would solely be
these businesses that are simply trying
to transition off of a kind of a legacy
utility tax that they really shouldn't
I'm unsure if there is or there isn't I
can always follow up and check with the
assessors um what I do know though is
that these utility generating properties
are as was kind of mentioned uniquely
different than like say a restaurant
just in their very nature and just in
how their ability to generate and how
much they generate and how much income
they make does greatly impact their
property their fair market value
so thank you
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank you for your testimony and I
want to close the public hearing on
House Bill
696 we'll immediately move to a public
hearing on House Bill
708 however I have no pink cards so I
don't know who to call
on
uh oh here we go we have a pink card
from the Bill's Prime sponsor
representative Horan so representative I
would recognize you to introduce House
Bill
708 if anyone else would like to testify
and House Bill 708 please submit a pink
you
um thank you very much I'm represented
Timothy Horgan from straford County
District 10 the town of uh the town of
Durham um and uh this bill actually you
may remember SB the rather appropriate
name SB 603 which you dealt with uh last
back last spring and this is a kind of a
follow on to that bill um with a
somewhat
different emphasizing one issue that was
kind of uh not at the Forefront of the
debate over that one which is
basically the possibility actually
probably the certainty that at some
point we'll have to have a second area
code in New Hampshire and it will be it
would have to um nobody would would have
wanted to have a geographic split of the
area code make half the state change
their numbers but that um I'm quite
certain will not happen they will they
would have an overlay area code but
anyway so 603 has been our state's only
area code since October 1947 when the
North American numbering Plan was
introduced
um at that time there were just 86
numbering plan areas in the United
States and Canada that that was before
we even had Direct distance dialing
which came in about 10 years later so
there and my red testimony says 335 area
codes I think actually what I meant is
there's 335 in the USA there's uh I
think I saw there's 53 in Canada there's
you know at least a couple of dozen in
in other parts of the world
so um it's probably more like four 400
area codes and then there's various
three-digit
codes um like you know the X11 codes
like 911 and
411 um you know so since the 1990s
there's been a lot of concern about
quote unquote exhausting the 603 area
code which means basically would run out
of available numbers and uh the north
numbering plan and U chis you probably
all know this it's there's a three-digit
area code um a three-digit central
office code code and finally a
four-digit station number or line
number and U the line and various
techniques have been utilized for the
past quarter Century the save off area
code 6 the exhaust date but the current
exhaust date is just seven years away in
2032 and um up till 1992 the only way to
create a new area code was a was a
geographic split like what what like
what we're concerned about happening in
which for example which is what we don't
want to have happen here in New
Hampshire um over late area Coast the
first one was back in 1992 when they
introduced area code 917 in New York
City I've personally lived through three
Geographic splits in the 1980s you know
they're kind of disruptive people were
scared about them but once they happened
they weren't as bad as people feared
beforehand but you know it's still
something we don't want to go through
here in New Hampshire
so and uh so in 19 you know so avoid the
geographic area split in 1992 the
general court enacted RSA
37459 which discouraged such a split
while powering the well it was as a pu
this function has been sent over to the
Department of energy to take various
measures to exhaust the supplies to
available phone numb is what we like to
fondly refer to as the
603 and those measures worked well but
it's been somewhat um it's been somewhat
expensive like s SP 603 spent I think um
a s allocate a six-digit sum for a
consultant to uh you know Stave off the
exhaustion of 603 which uh may or may
not have been money money well spent um
and I'm not even sure like who the
consultant was or what what they did but
at some point you know you know at uh
some point some point that effort is
going to become feudal you know some
point we're going to have to go to the
overlay area code and we're actually
starting to run out of phone numbers um
we're even running out of the central
office codes we're we have only we have
about 650 total of those you know
central office codes such as like the
271 on our phone numbers here in the
state house um where there's only 34
left I mean it could be worse the 617
area code in Boston has zero census
office codes available so and um this I
especially uh I became aware of this
issue personally when I had when I um
decided to get a Google Voice number and
Google Voice did not have any uh 603
numbers available because they couldn't
uh buy the rights to them I had to get
an
802 uh I had to get an 802 area code for
my Google Voice number so the
uh so anyway the
uh SP sp603 was a good Bill I'm not sure
if I agreed totally with its uh with the
emphasis on you know avoiding an overlay
area code but it was it uh it was
successful and there's basically zero
chance of a area of a geographic area
code split they haven't actually tried
to do one since 2007 it was that was in
New Mexico it was a fiasco it was
extremely
unpopular and it also I guess creates
more headaches for the people of the
North American numbering plan because
then they have to create a so-called
numbering second numbering plan area so
it's easier to keep the old numbering
plan area and just have a second or
third or however many area codes you
need to supply enough numbers so um I
think the creation of a second area code
would actually be
beneficial um I think you know telephone
users would have a choice of more
numbers so if you have a large business
you could now actually have your own
central office code again such as the
271 that the state government
uses um also you would also you would
have more choice of a of Sev digigit num
numbers that spell out a phrase so like
I could uh like so I could probably get
like a number like whatever the overlay
area code DT m o t y if I wanted i' like
to start have a phone number that
spelled up my name so um I would say I
would say it's a time you know I think
it's time to uh it's time to begin
planning for the introduction of an
overlay area code which I think U which
I think would I think would be
beneficial and you know we would still
be the 603 like I mentioned
Massachusetts and Boston you know the
617 area code has been you know 617 area
code is shrunk to a small geographic
area but you know if you go to Fenway
Park the Red Sox still have 617 on their
uh on 617 prbly featured their marketing
materials even on some of their baseball
caps so we would still be the 603 even
if we had a second area code and another
thing which I don't mention my written
testimony um is that uh if we if we if
we get the second area code now we have
more of a choice of a number to which to
choose and there's some that might be
popular that are still available I'll
just mentioned uh I think I think I'll
just mention something which one of my
colleagues pointed out which is like 420
popular with uh people the legalization
of cannabis 420 is still available as a
area code and there's some other uh
other cool numbers that are still
available you know though they actually
are running out of area codes too but
that's a whole another story so I I urge
you just to pass this bill it just uh
just Builds on what we passed last year
in SB 603 and just you know you know
kind of clarifies things also like maybe
recognize the reality that we're not
going to be able to one area code uh
forever and we'll still be to Hampshire
we'll still be the 603 even if we have
one or more overlay area codes in
addition to the 603 so that's sgy to
pass this bill thanks thank you could
you explain to us how an overlay area
code Works yes so it's similar I
mentioned for example in central Boston
there's uh the 617 and then lots of
people have 857 numbers as well so they
both uh apply to the same to the same
area and um so that's that's one near
nearby example or so and they mentioned
the nine like in 91 New York City
there's in Manhattan has a 212 they also
have the 646 and they also have the 917
that I talked about um Al the 917 is
special because 91 they shared 917 with
also like uh an area that was split off
back in the mid1 1980s basically in New
York City they did a geographical split
they split Manhattan off from the outer
and the Bronx off from the other three
burls and then they uh both those burls
have both those areas have several
overlay area codes in them and then they
have an overlay area code that overlays
both of them but that's a you know
that's basically just like you you see a
lot of Massachusetts for example
everybody the cell phones usually have
different numbers and the landlines
those are the newer overlay area codes
that were created I think thanks so hope
so over if I understand you correctly an
overlay area code is just a second area
code but it's not tied to a geographic
area well it's the same area well many
area there's many those area code what
we refer area codes aren't tied to
geographical areas but this is one
that's that would be where you have
multiple area codes for the same area so
if they did this New Hampshire would
still be what they call numbering plan
area but it would now have area code 603
and then whatever the area code is 420
or whatever one gets chosen for
us but when you dial your phone you only
have to use one area code correct um yes
you'll still have to do 10 digit dialing
but we we Institute which the which was
a stumbling block you know something
people were concerned about but we've
already crossed that bridge so we
already have 10 digit diing here in New
Hampshire so we got rid of that several
years ago for various reasons
so representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative hargan
for taking my question and I actually
have a a two-part question first one is
um what is it that the department of of
energy needs to do in terms of planning
and the second one is I noticed in the
bill there's a definition of geographic
split but that term is not used anywhere
in the bill okay the I think the
geographic split may appear elsewhere in
the RSA that it refers to um they um and
that's unnecessary well that's maybe
maybe that's something you consider
during the Comm process as um what was
the first part repeat the first part of
the question than first part was uh what
is it that the department of energy
would need to do in in terms of planning
for this um nothing special I'm just
trying to re redirect it SP 306 uh was
very
much was part of a campaign Governor the
former governor governor cunu he was uh
very interested in our state's iconic
symbols um I and the area code was was
one of them and so we have a new
governor who as far as I can tell is not
not quite as interested in symbolic
things like that so the overlay area
code is something that's going to have
to happen eventually so I think it's
probably better to have it sooner than
later so that's the purpose of adding
RSA additional questions representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um for
the record I highly endorse 420 and the
603 um my question though is how is a
how is a new area code chosen is it done
by contest is a petition I mean how how
is it applied well the there's a
organization called the North American
numing Plan area which is uh well it's a
private company but it contracts with
the various Nations that are in the
North American numbering plan area so
they uh and there's a somewhat
mysterious committee process so I I'd
have to say I'm not exactly sure how it
works but I'm sure if we uh but they do
respond if the you know this if the
department of energy if the state you
know if the department of energy says
we're ready to have the overlay area
code they'll start the process how they
decide which number to assign where I'm
not 100% sure but we have probably some
input over it and so thank thank further
questions representative McGee thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
hor Horgan for being here um my question
is whether it's the state that would
initiate that proceeding or whether the
telephone companies do that based on you
know that the need I mean who who's um I
understand the idea of wanting to get
the statutes updated which is fine but I
guess the point is where does the work
belong I mean there's there's many
telephone companies of State when we
first started the area cod plan back in
1947 there was just uh AT&T dominated
the market and they actually used to
administer this code which was first in
United States and Canada expanded like
various other places so the so this is
like within the purview of the it's in
the perview of the state to decide how
to allocate the numbers and they make
them available to all the different uh
telephone carriers of which there's
dozens or perhaps even even hundreds so
the largest two being um for rizon y and
FairPoint Communications but there's
okay seeing no further questions thank
you for introducing this legislation now
let's hear from the Department of energy
Stone good morning Mr chair and me
members of the committee my name is
Megan Stone legislative liaison with the
Department of energy so the department
is neutral on this bill however we do
have one main concern and that is the
state does not have jurisdiction over
um over area codes we cannot Reserve
area codes we cannot begin planning for
an area code on our own the North
American numbering plan administrator
has jurisdiction over when the planning
Begins for a new area code um Senate
Bill 603 in 2024 instructed the
department to adopt conservation
measures to save New Hampshire 603 area
code the department request Ed all
telecommunications providers that are
registered to provide telecommunication
Ser that provide telecommunication
service in New Hampshire and whom the
department has jurisdiction over to
undertake an inventory of their assigned
blocks of numbers and required them to
return those thousand blocks that were
less than 10% contaminated to the
numbering pool by March 31st 2024 close
to 150 blocks were returned following
that initial request the department has
also begun initial steps to move toward
consolidation of rate centers in New
Hampshire while rate Center
consolidation would not conserve or
reclaim numbers in the traditional sense
it could drastically reduce the quantity
of new 10,000 NXX codes that need to be
opened in the future using the efforts
already underway in the state of Maine
as a road map the department has
undertaken PR preliminary steps towards
that goal and has been holding
productive stakeholder sessions with
Consolidated Communications TDS Telecom
Granite State Communications Dunbarton
telephone company and Bretton Woods
telephone company prior to Senate Bill
603 being adopted the area code exhaust
date was anticipated to be quarter 2 of
2027 with a three-year planning period
for implementation of a new area code
Nampa would have begun planning efforts
in the second quarter of 2024
um Nampa does an analysis of the area
code exhaust dates in April and October
of each year because of the Department's
directive to to telecommunications
providers to inventory and review
numbering resources and return
non-contaminated blocks to the numbering
pool the April 2024 projection for
exhaust of the 603 was pushed out to the
third quarter of
2027 those efforts when combined with
continued close oversight and review of
daily requests for numbering resources
have continued to be successful and the
October 2024 analysis pushed the
projected exhaust date by almost two
years to the third quarter of 2029 and
the department anticipates that with um
continued implementation of the measures
we've taken uh that that will be pushed
out further in in the next couple of
reports and that is all I have happy to
take questions okay thank you very much
question questions for Miss Stone
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman thank you Miss stone for taking
my question so since you said that New
Hampshire doesn't have jurisdiction over
area codes is there anything that the
department of energy needs to do in
terms of getting a new overlay area code
Nampa will have the once they're looking
at the exhaust date if we come up to
that exhaust date and we don't have any
other uh and we think that will be the
case they will Implement a year planning
code follow but you said that was NAA
that would do that so my question was
about doe yes they will work with doe uh
once it once that once that exhaust date
comes up and they start that three-year
planning period NAA will work with
doe additional
questions seeing none thank you Miss
stone for being here that's good
detailed information we appreciate that
having no more pink cards I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
and I'm going to open a public hearing
on House Bill
hcr2 and call to the front table the
prime sponsor of this legislation
floor is yours representative welcome to
St thank you Mr chair and for the record
my name is Keith Ammon Hillsboro
District 42 New Boston Mount Vernon
lineb it's good to be before the science
technology and energy
committee they say some committees are
better looking but this committee has
IQ so I'm here to introduce HCR to
and the his the background on this bill
is or this
resolution is it's one of the
recommendations that came out of the
commission to investigate the
implementation of Next Generation
nuclear reactor technology in New
Hampshire that's the long title of the
commission uh I was going to give you
just a walk through
um resolutions are
symbolic they don't carry the force of
law
but it sends a signal to the country the
industry um that New Hampshire is
interested in this and we see the wisdom
in uh welcoming Advanced nuclear to New
Hampshire so just on page one of the
bill there's a lot of whereas
Clauses
um talks about the reliability and
efficiency of
nuclear it could contribute to the
state's energy independ
attendance um these next Generation
reactors offer improved safety
flexibility and
efficiency and generating clean carbon-
free
energy um on line 10 now um it could
provide opportunities for economic
growth job creation and Innovation
within New
Hampshire uh next whereas nuclear energy
currently supplies nearly 60% of New
Hampshire's instate electricity
generation
so new New Hampshire is already a
nuclear friendly
jurisdiction line 17 talks about the
global competition we learned a lot
about that on the on our
commission that Russia and China are
pursuing Supply chains globally and
they're locking in trading partners in
of different countries around the world
and they're becoming dependent on Russia
and China's Supply chains uh and the
United States is falling behind
currently in that area so it is a
national security issue as well um line
20 um it's in the interest of the United
States to maintain leadership in
advanced
technology and ensuring that it remains
under our nation's
control uh line
23 Workforce Development it it requires
a highly skilled and specialized
Workforce and so part of this resolution
is a resolution about Workforce
Development
and then finally line 27 we want to
nudge the NRC to speed up their uh
approval process of advanced nuclear and
they're working on something called part
54 which is uh regulations specifically
for advanced nuclear and uh the the
current Administration has asked them to
FastTrack that so this will be
reinforcing that idea so then 31 is the
resolution
resolved House of uh the House of
Representatives Senate concurring that
nuclear is hereby declared to be in the
best interest of the State of New
Hampshire and the United States
supporting energy Independence economic
growth carbon free energy generation and
technological
leadership the next page to line four
we're urging the NRC to
act line eight talks about the Workforce
Development of uh training programs to
build highly skilled Workforce necessary
so because this is sort of the the
ground floor maybe you could say of of
the advanced nuclear
Renaissance uh it's it would be wise for
our State University Systems and our
legislator to support them in building
the Workforce
Development the last section page two
line 11 I think of this
one uh maybe uh the days of Paul Riv
with uh a feather pin and an ink well
and a parchment we're sending this
resolution um to these various Federal
positions including the president of the
United
States uh the president of the US Senate
which is also the vice president the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
and then different committee chairs in
Washington DC and then at the state
level the governor commissioners of the
Pu commissioner of the Department of
energy and various other uh
departments so that's an overview of
this resolution and there's one trick
that I I didn't know years ago the the
Senate's
rules prevent them from taking up
concurrent
resolutions so if this passes the house
it will be my job to get a senator uh to
suspend the rule so that they can take
it up and fortunately we have three
Senators as co-sponsor so I think that's
the odds of that are are pretty high so
I'll with that I'll take any questions
thank you representative Vice chair
Thomas rather has a uh question for you
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so um very good
explanation on this I think it's well
needed with this resolution uh if it
passes the house and the HB 189 which
was the definition uh adding nuclear to
the definition of clean energy passing
the house both of these put together
would you say that this uh is an attempt
to tell the world that we are ready for
nuclear energy investors to come to the
state and is this going to the qu uh
this following question is is this going
to add Credence to the National effort
by seeing another state is adopting this
type of resolution I believe so and I
think we'll be the only state in the
Northeast to do so because U most of the
other states have moratoriums on
building Nuclear So
this is a comparative advantage for our
state in New England and as you said
it'll send a signal that we're
interested in developing this industry
here additional questions representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Ammon for introducing
this bill um I'm looking forward to
hearing more about Advanced nuclear in
the emerging Tech caucus one of the
questions I have though is about the
workforce uh there isn't really uh
established Advanced nuclear anywhere so
how do you how do we spin up education
for a Workforce I I don't think there
are professors at UNH who can teach it
um or anywhere else in the state so how
how do we spin that up that's a good
question so this resolution it doesn't
carry the force of law it's really just
a a strong
suggestion uh on the commission for
Advanced nuclear we had a professor from
UNH a professor of physics uh sit in on
the commission so I do know there's at
least one qualified person to teach it
um the supply chain for advanced nuclear
isn't just going to be about the
radioactive components or the reactor
components there's a lot of different uh
you know parts that go into
manufacturing it so for instance in
Newington Westinghouse has a
manufacturing facility they manufacture
part parts of nuclear reactor plants and
so we do have some some seeds in New
Hampshire that we can grow to uh you
know benefit from the supply chain and
Workforce Development would be a big
that representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um I'm looking on page two
line five where it says um well lines
four and five that the New Hampshire
General Court urges the nuclear
Regulatory Commission to prioritize and
expediate the review and approval
process are you advocating for any steps
or processes to be changed in order to
expediate these processes or these uh
reviews I think you mean expedite but
same difference I think no expedite
sorry um yeah we're we're urging them to
uh it's it's a gentle urging that this
has taken too
long uh you know
uh Quicken their pace and you know not
compromise safety but make sure that the
industry has some certainty on when they
can comply with whatever regulations
that they're going to develop followup
followup surely you have an idea of how
this could be accomplished to speed
things up yes I
do could you
elaborate uh they can uh improve their
their processes
and the the big issue is that they're
trying to shoehorn advanc nuclear into
the old regulations for old generation
nuclear reactors and so they need to
adopt and they are they're doing this
they're adopting a an approach that fits
the nature of advanced nuclear and not
trying
to uh not slowing that process down by
treating Advanced nuclear as if it's as
dangerous as the older generation
Nuclear So that would be that would be
my thought thank
you
so the NRC has approved a small modular
reactor design by new
scale they have also approved the
building of two molten salt reactors in
Texas by a company called
Kos do you think the momentum is
starting to build for advanced nuclear
resource ources I do um just
coincidentally while I was sitting
waiting I got I I noticed this email
that I'd like to mention it's
from
uh it's from Terra power which is a
advanced nuclear company it's uh backed
by Bill Gates they're building a plant
in
chemer uh
Wyoming and uh it's called the natrium
plant and
they they received a permit to build a
station unit one this month the permit
covers all construction and operational
activities on the natrium plant that are
not under the jurisdiction of the NRC so
they're getting started waiting for the
NRC and it's a significant Milestone
they say it would make United States a
first mover in commercial Advanced
nuclear and interestingly they've
partnered up with a data center one of
the largest data center Builders um Sab
data centers so in their announcement
they're announcing that they're
partnering with a large data center um
and I'll tell you if I had a little more
chance little opportunity olc was a
little backed up they were kind of
bombarded with a lot of bills so I
didn't have a chance to kind of
highlight this but um if you wanted to
make a an improvement to this my
suggestion on page
one uh line 13 that paragraph there I
think would be the best place for it to
emphasize uh that we understand that
data centers AI uh Data Centers High
high performance compute data centers
are uh driving the demand for advanced
nuclear and I would have added that had
I had the opportunity but it does say uh
it does list some manufacturing
Industries and businesses and so forth
but you might want to put data center
something about data center in that
paragraph
excellent further questions
representative
Harrington yeah um just I just a couple
quick comments on questions that could
probably add to this the you're probably
aware that the state of Texas has filed
lawsuit against the NRC saying that on
certain small modular reactors that they
should not have jurisdiction so so that
is is pending out there and as far as
the workforce uh issue goes that's
become a major issue with the American
nuclear society which by the way I got
my golden award yesterday 50 years
member oh congrats and uh they estimate
200,000 people are going to be needed
but that's been identified as a major
issue that they are working on as one of
their top priorities to get that
qualified Workforce because it's simply
has gone away because we haven't been
building nuclear plants so
inter further
questions representative Kap thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
Ammon for bringing this bill I I uh I
support support your aims I think I
agree with that uh you know n Advanced
nuclear is becoming an important
component and will be an important
component of our Energy Mix in the
future I do have you know just to share
a little editorial I I do have some
concern about the data centers is
driving this and fact that you know
where is that benefit going to going to
land in terms of uh you know our
constituents um but I I just wanted to
ask you a question in terms of Workforce
Development do would you agree that that
in order to develop the necessary
Workforce this we're going to have to
fund education in a lot more serious
fashion in our state I think we're very
creative in how we fund things in New
Hampshire so I agree that funding is a
component and where that comes from
determined representative L relle has a
question thank you Mr chair uh I think
nuclear has a great deal of potential
but I'm also wondering if I'm concerned
that a lot of the uranium War comes from
places like China and
Russia my question is will we go back
and do some more research on say thorium
beer reactors and other uh potential
sources of nuclear
energy it's a good question um I I'm my
lay understanding is that the thorium
reactor concept has great promise but
it's just not as far ahead as fishing
you know uranium based fish
uh in the commission we did interview or
had present uh a nuclear fusion company
so nuclear fusion is I'm a little
skeptical if if you can get you know
energy for free but uh they seem to
think that they're on the verge of
possibly some breakthroughs with fusion
um and that has a lot less a fewer
issues with
radioactivity you know the the
byproducts so that's the best I can
answer thank you representative parall
has a question thank you chair Von thank
you for being here
today
um I do have concerns about this
technology competing with existing uh
non-fossil fuel
Alternatives um however setting that
aside my other concern is us getting
these funded uh nuclear which was was
that the name of the uh um new scale new
scale scale MH um recently had many of
their contracts uh cancelled in Utah
which was Idaho which caused them you
know basically to send their company in
a freeold right now and
uh I'm not aware of any other company
right now that's been able to amass the
capital in order to proceed with a
fullscale project such of this of this
nature I'm not saying it can't happen
but I miss would like your perspective
on that so we all have limited knowledge
right so your question isn't
definitive I'm going to I'm going to
assume um I just read you a press
release from Terra power in Wyoming
that's backed by Bill Gates and the data
center demand is huge and there's a lot
of private Capital coming from data
centers because they need the energy to
run their computers so there there may
be if we play our cards right there may
be way to attract private Capital to
help fund these projects and there there
are some uh you're right it was uamps in
Utah uh the
municipality there was there was a a
short seller that put out a
report and that sort of blew up that
deal they they they they claimed the
numbers didn't work out and the
municipality agreed and they pulled out
of that project um data centers are
you know very highly capitalized we just
saw Microsoft is going to restart one of
the reactors in Three Mile Island so
they're F they're trying to find ways to
get carbon free firm power and that's
what they're looking for and advanced
nuclear nuclear in general fits that
bill very very nicely it's 247 always on
and reliable power for you know the the
contracts that these data centers have
with their customers you know you've
probably heard of 59 uptime
99.999 perc uptime that's the the
standard um and you need power to to you
know deliver that
uptime uh followup please yes followup
yes um so we you would see the primary
role of many of these uh smrs is uh
being tied directly which we did hear
Bill yesterday of this nature being tied
directly to these data centers rather
than providing uh electric generally
into our existing grid I mean is that
kind of what I I don't think that's a
fair assumption so in order for a
project to be uh capitalized you know
the business plan has to map out and
what you need is the first customer you
need a customer that's going to sign a
contract power agreement stating that th
that customer the data center whatever
it is is going to make that project
uh viable once that's met once that
reactor is built any extra power can go
back to the grid and feed the customers
of New Hampshire the the businesses and
the residences in New Hampshire so you
just have to think about how it scales
out thank you that's a good answer thank
you thank
you f questions representative M
representative schnella
refers thank you chairman Vose um
my question is
uh relative to the last uh last question
any good plan has to start with
leadership and I think leadership will
have to come from the executive
specifically the governor um have you or
any of the tech caucus had any material
discussions with the governor's office
um because that that's a critical
component to any plan that's a good
question
um Ju Just anecdotal
the few times that I've seen Governor
aot I've seen her three or four times
the last couple of months and she
mentions to me advanced nuclear Keith we
want to do Advanced Nuclear So I know
and she said it in her uh inaugural
address um in debates so I know there's
interest I I've been kind of waiting for
the budget process to work out because I
know that's the main priority of the
governor's office and once once that
gets settled we're going to have her
address on Thursday so I think after
that after that budget is passed off to
the house the governor's office will
have more uh time to pursue different
things and I plan on following up with
that and if you want to be included I'd
appreciate that too thank you thank
you now representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
Ammon for taking my question so um what
I thought reading through the resolution
I'm I'm happy that you're bringing it I
think it's Timely um but it seems like
it's a there's maybe a disconnect with
where the resources are in the country
and perhaps the the resolution could
also include a call for the federal
government to in to pull in our our um
our
existing
um I'm going blank now like losal and
our National Labs basically we have
technologists in those areas that are
highly skilled and that are often idle
in administrations that don't know how
to use those resources in order to
advance um the goals of the country so
I'm wondering whether it's appropriate
for the resolution to also include a
call for the National Labs to be I I'm
sure they are already involved but um
perhaps that's another piece because
when you're talking about trying to
figure out a way to get the workforce
together for this which really is an
issue um um I would think that if you're
looking all Hands-On deck that might be
a good addition to the bill is to direct
that because they they never seem to use
the National Labs in any really pointed
way I um I think that's a excellent
suggestion I know there's a project p in
I think it's Idaho National Labs that's
a a test reactor and there there's a the
gain program which is uh I always forget
what it stands for Gateway for
acceleration and nuclear I think it
stands for um and they've had
representative in state um trying to
work with the Department of energy and I
think even Dartmouth so there are some
federal resources that can be brought to
bear and I also know the the startup in
Manchester star cube has gotten plugged
into the National Lab system and they're
benefiting from you know they're doing
reactor design and so they're able to
tap into those resources which I think
suggestion additional
questions seeing none thank you
representative for introducing this
resolution we have no more pink cards is
there anybody else who would like to
speak Mr chairman just a a quick comment
yes representative Harrington on on as
far as the National Labs go they'll be
evaluating the there six prototype
projects that were funded by the federal
government of various types of smrs and
they're going for what it looks like to
be built and it'll be sometime I think
the deadline is the end of 2026 but
these are small prototypes and I think
we'll know a lot more after that comes
out but there is actual work being done
and it's being directed I think by
Oakridge on this one
so representative
bernardy just another comment when you
start looking at at Workforce and and uh
looking for skilled people in this area
you don't forget that uh Naval Shipyard
has been a nuclear uh engineering
lab operational for years and years
there are many well-trained nuclear uh
um workers in that Arena as well as we
have uh SE brick nuclear power plant so
New Hampshire is very well um suited for
having at least a start in some highly
okay any additional
comments seeing none we are now going to
take a lunch break and we will return
here at
1:00 for a public hearing on House Bill
FN enabling Electric utilities to own
operate and offer Advanced nuclear
resources we will see you all then and
enjoy your lunch Mr chairman quick
question
yes representative re do you anticipate
uh any uh executive sessions this
afternoon after our scheduled public
hearings well since you brought that
up we could do one right now before we
break for lunch if you like I was just
asking are there any bills that we
probably could come to um bipartisan
um does anybody want to make a
suggestion I would suggest the bill on
suggestion well what what is your motion
on
it yeah what your motion my motion would
be uh itl I just don't as we heard from
the people from the Department of energy
it's not necessary there's already
activities going forward you can stretch
it out for so long and I don't think
that this bill is going to add to that
at all so besides we're also told that
the department of energy doesn't have
authority to do what the bill is asking
it to
do all right let's have a show of hands
of people who would probably go uh who
would be likely to go along with a
708 all right looks like a a majority
uh would agree to that so let's call an
executive session then on House Bill
7008 and I recognize representative
Harrington for a motion I I move
inappropriate to legislate on House Bill
708 I recognize representative
McGee and I will second that motion
moved and seconded that we adopt the
motion of itl on House Bill 7008 further
discussion
seeing
none I'm going
to see if I can delay things for a few
minutes so the clerk can get his
paperwork act together so that we can
actually do this sorry to Spring this on
you so unexpectedly but it was um a
little bit
unexpected on my part too until
representative rols suggested that it
so I think it's a good idea if if if we
can reach consensus as a committee why
not you know dispose of these bills when
we have the opportunity in this case
it's an itl but it could have been an
OTP if we all agree
so Arrington and who did the second
second by representative McGee so it's
been moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of itl on the
question of on House Bill 708 rather so
I would ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of the motion of itl on
uh HB 708 Vice chair Thomas yes yes a is
G uh representative Harrington
yes Rey representative Bernardi yes
representative
PL yes Summers uh representative Matson
yes representative schneller yes
representative
McGee yes Representative parshall
no representative Kaplan yes
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman Vose
yes two three four five six seven eight
n 10 11 12 13 14
to1 by a vote of 14 to one the committee
708 without objection we'll put this on
the consent
calendar no objection noted so this bill
will go on the consent calendar and
representative Harrington will write the
committee
report no Minority Report report is
necessary with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill
708 and we have a few more minutes does
anybody have another suggestion for an
an executive session
bill I personally do not but
representative scheller would 672 be too
involved
to address at this time
672 refresh our memory uh allow for
offgrid electricity providers in New
Hampshire yes I I don't think we're
ready for that one I think maybe an
amendment might be necessary for that
suggestions
hcr2 um I think we had talked about a
possible amendment to that but we could
we could go without one if you wanted um
I think you should do the amendment
makes more powerful on the floor okay
it's been suggested that we wait for an
amendment on that
one
ideas purely in the interest of making
possible okay seeing none
representative
McGee thank you Mr chair I'm reading
through the list here and I'm wondering
if we could look at HB
535 which is relative to defining the
role of the Public Utilities
Commission and I would be in favor of
OTP because I know all that does is
basically say that it requires two
Commissioners to make
decisions um no that's not the that's
not the one no we already exec that one
so which is this one this is the one
that uh don Cree had written um removing
the enforcement from the Pu oh oh yeah
yeah okay sorry about that so I don't
know if we're ready to vote on that I
don't think we're ready for that one
we're not ready s right we don't want to
okay all right
well we might have time this afternoon
if any other ideas occur to you at 7 at
1:00 we're going to hear House Bill
710 requiring Electric utilities to own
operate and offer Advanced nuclear
resources I would guess that bill would
probably need an amendment so that one
probably won't be a candidate and then
at
1:30 probably for the remainder of the
afternoon we're going to be hearing HB
764 which is
the bill that prohibits the intentional
release of polluting emissions including
cloud seeding weather modification
excessive electromagnetic radio
frequency and microwave radiation I can
make a motion on that one right
now well I think we have to have the
public hearing first but I I I
appreciate your sentiments on that one
well will we have the five o'l deadline
on that we do have a five o' deadline
good but if we should by some uh Stroke
of Luck finish at 4:30 we could consider
an executive session on that bill or any
other Bill Mr chairman I have another
bill potential okay um we just voted uh
we just voted on the area code Bill
directing the department of energy we
have another bill like that which is
directing the department of energy to
investigate the state's withdrawal from
the isoo
I don't think there's going to be any
that how many people would what would
bill well I I don't really agree with
the premise of pulling out so I don't
really agree with asking them to waste
their time studying it but that's just
my personal opinion I think we still
have to vote the bill out of committee I
just think it's probably ready to vote
out of
committee I'm actually waiting for some
information from the um the committee
bill is there any other comment on the
possibility that we might take up that
bill vice chair Thomas U yes Mr chairman
No I um I think we needs just a little
more thought U maybe until next week I I
have a thought I want to present to the
uh chairman uh as to how we might want
to perhap perhaps have a an amendment
but it's just a thought um before we
make a decision right now that the
thought could be done over lunch as well
so I just want to have a little bit of
time to talk about
it okay representative Swanson Mr chair
earlier uh speaking of information uh
did you mention that you had sent out a
or fored a 40 page report uh earlier on
696 uh yes Davis Allen the committee
researcher sent it to um all members
probably to their legislative email so I
should look for something from Davis yes
correct turn on your microphone please
it's also cited as a hot link in the
letter from the New England power
generators Association can get it that
way
too thank you yes representative McGee
thank you um so I just had a thought we
had quite a bit of test quite a bit of
testimony yesterday um on the on HB 723
and then I also had the presentation I
did in the morning on um
681 I'm wondering if we could um
entertain a motion to retain the bills
related to the data platform because we
don't yet have the information on the
cost uh or the cost benefits so after 5
and a half years of work I think the
committee could probably um Supply that
for the certainly the members who've
donated their time and uh the people all
over the country who've been trying to
help us get to this as a state um so I
I'm just I would ask that we could
probably vote on those two bills but not
up or down based on our IND individual
feelings but to be retained so that we
can receive the information that they've
been working to develop all these years
Vice chair Thomas uh thank you Mr
chairman uh it just so happens that and
just this for information it just so
happens that this morning at the chair
Vice chair meeting um clerk Paul Smith
talked about retaining bills and just as
a reminder that any bill that was put uh
for
retain we would not be able to discuss
it as a committee until the end of June
and because of the active bills that are
going forth now in in the in the the
state house and as we all know when we
come to July uh we can certainly start
taking a retained bills but it will not
be in the L it'll be in the other
location to be named later and any bills
put on retained would not be able to
come up before the house until the
following year year
reminder okay so I I'm not personally
ready to make a judgment on whether
those bills should be retained so I
don't think we can do anything on that
today representative Corman thank you uh
I actually like the idea of retaining
them because the rfps won't really be
coming in until August is what we're
told so we can't really do anything
until the fall and uh to Vice chair
Thomas's point about that any retained
bills would be heard in the location to
be named um well that'll give us good
practice in in dealing with it without a
interference
okay like I said I don't think we should
consider that today but at a future date
I'm sure we can consider that
representative
Swanson uh being a new guy here uh am I
understanding that uh this would uh
extend I mean does the committee
normally meet uh beyond the Fourth of
July through the summer
season so retain means that the
committee hangs on to the bill it
doesn't turn it over to the house with a
recommendation because the committee has
decided it wants to do additional work
on the bill so what happens is the
retained bill is typically taken up in
the fall after the summer
recess
and there is a deadline it's usually
somewhere around the 12th or 15th of
November that all retained bills have to
be reported out so what would happen is
in the fall we'd get back together and
we'd say okay we retain these two bills
what are we going to do with it we have
to have a report by November the report
has to be ought to pass or
itl and uh we would figure that out make
a recommendation and that would happen U
by the deadline in November so the
reference to the alternative to the L
yet to be named isn't like right
sometime in July it's the time frame you
mentioned correct the the the the
discussion of the
lob revolves around the fact that on
July 1st the lob closes for one year and
all future committee activity after that
date takes place at a building somewhere
else here in conquer I'm not exactly
sure where where it is um and so that's
going to
impact our activity for the year that
the L is closed because we're not going
to be right next door to the state house
like we are now we're not going to be
right next door to OS like we are right
now we're not going to be right next
door to the cafeteria like we are right
now so uh a lot of the activity that we
engage in over that year is going to be
quite different um for example let's say
you've introduced a
bill
um that the Senate is hearing well the
Senate is going to continue hearing
bills in the state house but you're
going to be in the building that the
house is using to hear its
bills and I don't know the exact
distance between the buildings but I
think it's maybe a half a mile or more
or more so you're not going to be able
to just you know run out the door and
say I got to dash over to the state
house to testify on a Senate bill or a
bill before the Senate you're going to
have to carefully plan your
activity um with regard to bills that
are being heard before the Senate so
it's going to be
complicated but and it's going to be new
to all of us because this is my 11th
year as a state representative i' I've
never had to do something like that
before to meet in your car so pardon you
get to meet in your car understood I
just I I wanted to make sure I I was
inferring that we were going to take it
up right after the new replacement L was
open but I understand your schedule now
there's no mileage paid um between July
1st and about August 15th therefore most
of us would prefer not to conduct any
legislative business during that period
of time since we don't get reimbursed
for
mileage and the speaker's office
discourages us from doing any
legislative business during that time so
typically you don't take up a retain
September you ready to go to lunch
all right let's go to lunch we'll see
1:00
e
we'll start in a few seconds people can
place okay good afternoon everyone
welcome to the afternoon session of uh
Science Tech and energy this afternoon
we will be looking at two bills HB 710
FN enabling Electric utilities to own
operate and offer Advanced nuclear
resources and later on uh at 130ish HB
764 FN uh prohibiting the intentional
Rel release of polluting emissions um
yada yada yada for right now I'd like to
open up the public hearing for HB 710 FN
and uh introduce representative chairman
V to introduce the
Bill thank you Mr Vice chairman and good
afternoon again committee members for
the record representative Michael Bose
town of eeping Rockingham 5 and I'm here
this this afternoon to introduce House
Bill 710
FN which will allow Electric utilities
to own operate or offer Advanced nuclear
resources here in the state of New
Hampshire I view this as in in
legislation it's based on the model of R
RSA um 574
enabled utilities to pursue the
ownership of renewable energy
resources that statute was actually
passed many many many years ago but is
never actually used until very recently
when Unitil built a or or got permission
to build a five megawatt solar farm
in Kingston I believe is the location
correct um that facility is currently
under construction and will probably
come online sometime in the spring or
year so 574g enabled that project and I
have
followed the same model here to add
nuclear Advanced nuclear resources to
that model the first task of the bill is
to Define what Advanced nuclear resource
means and that is on page one of the
bill line three and four where it
defines an advanced nuclear Resource as
any micro mini or small nuclear reactor
having a generating Capac capacity
between 1 and 90
megaw
now the nuclear industry frequently
defines Advanced nuclear resources to be
up to 300
megawatts and I chose 90 for the
purposes of this bill mostly to get a
conversation started it could even be
potentially as low as 30 for the upper
limit or it could go go up to 300
that's a detail and a decision that we
could make collectively as a
committee so that's what the first
section of the bill does is it inserts
the definition AD of advanced nuclear
resources into
statute section two of the bill restu
restructuring policy
principles which is lines 5 through 30
on page
1 and lines
1 through 18 on page
two this is actually
unnecessary text that doesn't actually
need to be in this bill and so I'm going
to uh State on the record now that I am
in favor of removing via
amendment that portion of this
legislation um once we decide whether or
not we're going to adopt
it so the essence of the bill then
starts on page two line 19 section
three and this is the section that I
described as
enabling New Hampshire utilities
to invest in advanced nuclear resources
forces and this follows the model of the
existing statute that enables
the investments in distributed energy
resources which typically
means solar or wind or
Hydro so
the the key wording
is
that text that's starts on line 22 and
is in bold and allows 15% for advanced
nuclear resources as defined in RSA 374
F2 which we defined at the very
beginning of the
legislation this 15% limit is also a
and then in line
26 this is a a line that talks about
the in in section two line 22 talks
about an individual project in line 26
in Section 3 talks about cumulative
projects owned by a single uh
utility and 8% in that line is also a
starting point for dis
discussion and then the fourth section
uh
a assignment of Duties to the
coordinator of nuclear development and
Regulatory activities which is an
existing
house statutory position and it just
this text just gives to that office
additional
duties um with regard to nuclear
activities in New Hampshire and
surrounding
states and the the new text the text on
the bottom of page two is existing text
and then the new text on the top of Page
Three is the text that the bill adds to
include the management of funding and
oversight of nuclear incentive programs
such as those described in our Essa 374
G4 which is the text that was modified
on the previous page as well as to uh as
well as Outreach programs to inform and
educate the public particularly
regarding safety so that's what the bill
does and the purpose of the bill is
future activity for advanced nuclear
resources there probably isn't going to
be any kind of immediate activity on the
part of the state's utilities to jump on
the bandwagon and start building
Advanced nuclear
resources it might be 10 years from now
before anybody took advantage of this
legislation but that happened with the
it took 15 or 20 years before somebody
took advantage of this legislation so
it's enabling
legislation and it tells the world that
New Hampshire is open for business when
it comes to nuclear energy it also ties
in uh kind of neatly to
the um the house resolution that we P
that we heard earlier today that once
make the same declaration that New
Hampshire wants to be involved in
forward we've all heard the talk about
the growth of data centers and the the
promise of the explosive growth of
AI all of which is going to be extremely
power hungry
and the
likelyhood the likelihood is that it
will require some kind of nuclear energy
to meet those growing energy demands so
to enable New Hampshire to get in in on
the ground floor of some of that
activity is why I introduce this bill
and uh why I think it's important for us
to move forward to show that we're ready
when the time comes to take advantage of
advanced nuclear resources and with that
I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you representative o
excellent testimony on an issue that we
all know is coming and we welcome all
the U messaging we can get to tell New
Hampshire investors that we're open for
business questions I'll I'll start with
uh representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr Vice chair I'm I'm
shocked
um so on on page two just a
clarification on line 34 you talk about
the coordinator of nuclear development
where does that position lie is it under
the department of energy or is it within
pu
or where does that coordinator
live it is the Department of energy I
believe it's the office of energy
Innovation okay but the doe is here they
can clarify that okay if I'm
wrong
Bernardi thank you Mr chair uh so if I
am understanding this right you are in
this draft anyway limiting the size of a
reactor to 90 megawatt and utilities
ownership to no more than
15% so that would be a maximum of 13 12
megawatts of size that they could have
their hands around is that
correct so the first part of your
question was about the definition
limiting the size to 90
megawatts
um as I said in my introduction
negotiable that number is Up For Debate
and I think we should have that debate
and decide what the best number
is the second part of your question was
about the 15% number on line 22 on page
to that relates to the utili Total
distribution Peak load in
megawatts
uh that could be up you know 15% of that
could be provided by Advanced nuclear
resources so the utility's Total
distribution Peak load depends on the
utility uh the bigger the utility the
bigger the the peak
load thank you
representative McGee thank you Mr Vice
chair and thank you Mr chairman for
taking my question so as many of you
know I'm married to a PhD nuclear
engineer and one of the things that he
has uh mentioned to me over time is that
an issue with the smaller reactors and
micro reactors is the cost um to
implement them that it's not cost
effective so I just did a quick search
here and um it says that a 90 megawatt
scale nuclear reactor an SMR would cost
anywhere between 300 million and 900
million to build and then the cost per
kilowatt would be ranging from 3,000 to
5,000 per kilowatt so my question is um
I understand the aim of the bill uh but
it does two things that concern me it
undoes um 374 in terms of its attempts
to deregulate and take the utilities out
of the generation market and it kind of
reverses that by asking them to get back
in a major way to generation but it also
puts the rate pairs on the hook for what
could be really exorbitant costs so if
we're worried about little costs like
paying for Energy Efficiency and uh
renewable energy fund and that kind of
thing we're cutting things like that it
this would be very counterproductive in
terms of what people would be
on um on the is your question what the
right thing people would be on the hook
for a substantial amount of money and
they wouldn't be able to get away from
it because they'd be able to be
reimbursed right I that's what I'm
that's what I'm asking I'm just saying
the cost piece of it seems like it's not
a good thing to
enable yes I I was just waiting for you
to finish before I responded I really
appreciate that you're absolutely right
that the cost estimates for these
reactors today are very high
but as we discussed when we talked about
HCR
4 we're on the cusp of a significant
revolution in small modular reactors and
as they get built in more in more in
larger and larger numbers we're going to
see the costs come
down and then there are companies like
starcube which are building very small r
actors in The 1 to 5 Mega megawatt range
which are much less expensive than the
the ones that you cited uh probably
still too expensive to make a difference
right now but eventually those costs
have the potential to come down and what
I'd like to see and I think a lot of
people in New Hampshire would like to
see is that when those costs do get into
the range of feasibility it we're ready
to move and adapt that technology adopt
possible uh yes represent McGee let's
play a little game here let's play
Jeopardy and put your answer in the form
of a
question I find that so difficult but I
will try so the question is uh does it
make sense for us to pass a bill that
allows the utilities to go back into
owning
generation uh when we spent so much time
uh eliminating that ability on the rap
Paradigm well we allow it for
distributed any energy resources so I
adopted that model for for this
legislation uh if it's good for
distributed energy resources why
shouldn't it be good for advanced
nuclear resources it seems to me that
they're they're both equally valid
resources they're both Clean Energy
Technologies
so uh if it's good enough to do it for
deers it's good enough to do it for a
anrs I
think representative
Harrington yeah just I just a little
back of the uh envelope calculation it
looks like to me the
15% uh of the uh total distrib bution
Peak would be somewhere in the vicinity
of about 300 megaw so we're talking
about a substantial amount of purchase
that would be able here and my
understanding is it would be in no
larger than 90 megawatt blocks so
because that would be the maximum size
that would qualify would be 90
megaw so are we talking about reversing
restructuring and going back to the old
way where the rate payers take the risk
rather than the stockholders and if
you're saying the price is going to come
down because these going to be money
many of these are going to be built then
why do we need to go back to the rate
payers taking the risk and let the
stockholders do it if someone wants to
invest in these when the price becomes
affordable they'll invest in it we don't
need to have the utilities or the rate
payers funding the utilities again as a
back
stop and I'm not advocating that the Pu
in the docket that Unitil brought
forward to recover its costs for
developing its 5 megawatt deer facility
in Kingston
had to justify those costs as being just
and reasonable to rate payers and so any
project brought forward under this
legislation would also have to go before
the Pu and be justified as uh just and
reasonable before it could go forward so
if as you say this turns out to be
extremely expensive then the Pu will say
no and not allow it to be built or cost
recovered followup follow up I just may
add that most of the costs from seabook
will declared Justin reasonable too and
you look what that got us I just think
this is a major change that we ought to
it see more other questions thank you
representative good testimony uh next
I'll call up to the desk Mr Megan Stone
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Megan Stone
legislatively as on with the Department
of energy and I'm joined here by Matt
Young um an attorney with the Department
um so the department is neutral on House
Bill 710 and the department appreciates
the sponsors and Alle legislature's
intent to show that New Hampshire is
open for business to advance nuclear and
other resources this bill is the latest
effort of many that show how seriously
the committee is taking resource
adequacy challenges that face New
England as introduced the department has
two points that we would just like to
bring to the committee's attention um
House Bill 710 intro includes anr
options alongside renewable energy
sources for Utilities in RSA 374 F2 um
the restructuring statute the department
would like to urge thoughtfulness
regarding adding exceptions to the
statute should more be added the
department would ask the committee to
consider whether this moves away from
the original intent of
restructuring and the department
believes uh also that there could be a
risk of stranded cost should these
structures be built um the department
believes there is a risk that all payers
could end up on the hook um for this the
department is not uh opposed to the idea
proposed by House Bill 710 however the
bill represents a very significant
change and the department believes
taking a method method methodical sorry
holistic approach could add value
whether that is through a department L
investigation into anr's study committee
or another mechanism further thought to
ensure it is done correctly and to
protect rate payers in the future New
Hampshire should not just lead the way
but also set a good example for the rest
of New England on how to get energy
policy done right um and also I believe
that there was a question earlier about
um nuclear coordinator position that is
under the department um it's currently
under the office of offshore wind
Innovation thank you questions for the
uh Department representative Harrington
yeah just a quick one on the that uh new
the nuclear development regulatory or
whatever that coordinator is called is
that an existing position or are you
planning on hire if this was passed
would you hire a new person to fill that
it is existing it's existing right now
okay yes representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chairman my
question goes to your first point I
believe in that you um asked us to take
caution in making changes I guess to
374f because it it looks like it's uh
moving from its original intent could
you talk a little more about the intent
that you're concerned about preserving
take
that thank you for the question um again
Matt Young For the record um so the
intent of the uh restructuring policy
principles um that are included in this
statute was to uh divest utilities from
Generation Um and then obviously 374 G
represents a sort of a carve out I guess
to that um so any expansion of that 374
G
um language or uh projects that could be
included within that framework uh would
uh could be viewed as sort of diverging
from that um divesture goal of
restructuring thank
you additional questions representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thanks for
coming in today um I have a similar
question and that is uh concerning the
the uh issue you raised with stranded
costs and some of the concerns you might
have about stranded costs because we
know that is an issue that has plagued
uh you know previous iterations of
nuclear energy in our state um and
elsewhere so could you talk a little bit
more about specifically what would lead
to those kind of stranded costs in
installations so under the uh 374 G
framework um these projects are approved
in a uh
two-phase uh approach so first the um
the utilities um request for uh
authorization from the from the Public
Utilities Commission to um kind of get
underway with these projects and they
find that whether they're in the public
interest and then phase two of that once
they're built the utilities come in um
and will present all their costs in a
rate case and the those um costs are
determined whether it be prudent or not
in that second phase I hope that I hope
that answers your question
followup go ahead I I was hoping to get
more specificity around what leads to
those stranded cost issues why would why
would a utility or or any operator of a
nuclear installation come in that second
phase and claim stranded costs what
would those stranded costs consist
of um you know I think the utilities
could speak to what what could become a
stranded cost I think what what would
end up becoming stranded costs are any
any cost deemed imprudent um the the
utilities would have to cover those um
but
question representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so my question would be um
where the authority rests for nuclear
power currently coming into the state
because I think when C Brook came it was
really a federal project and there might
have been citing concerns and local
coordination but does the Public
Utilities Commission under existing New
Hampshire statute currently have
oversite for nuclear power in any way or
is that would that be something that
would need to be rectified because I
don't I don't think it's in their
purview is it there's certainly federal
regulations and federal oversight I'm
not entirely clear I'd have to go back
and check on uh the site evaluation
but follow up so then without changes to
statute it may be true that they
wouldn't have any um statutory oversight
for something like nuclear power coming
into the state
correct I'd have to go back and look at
clear further
questions representative
Harrington yeah just to follow up to
that question would this is kind of like
piggybacking on the the distributed uh
elect electricity that we already
allowed the utilities to buy IE the five
megawatt plant down in Kingston I guess
so whatever regulations there that the
Pu possessed in order to economically
regulate a plant it wouldn't make any
difference whether it was one of under
that provision or was under this new
Advanced nuclear provision correct I
think the provisions are already in the
financial regulation is already in the
law could you say could you say that a
different way maybe not sure I I'm sorry
right now the the law says you can build
distributive generation or renewable
generation up to 6% of the utility Total
distribution Peak and someone stated
earlier that they that would have that
project that's being currently built
would have to go through the Pu and
they'd have to show that the costs were
just and reasonable what we've done
under this bill is to expand that to
include these Advanced nuclear reactors
so am I correct in assuming that
whatever economic regulation that would
app already is in the law for the
distributed generation would now apply
to Advanced nuclear reactors and in fact
the Pu would have Financial regulatory
Authority so 374 G does include
considerations and factors that the
commission does have to consider when
improving these projects um and those
those would apply under this legislation
to um I guess any any anr projects okay
thank
you further questions
seeing none want to thank you two for
being here next we'll call up Molly
Connors from New
England um power generators
Association I think I recognize you
haven't I seen you here
before coming a frequent flyer thank you
all it's nice to see you all again um
for the record Molly Connor with NEPA
the New England power generators
Association as a reminder we represent
the non-utility owned gener facilities
in the region um region wide we
represent about 27,000 megawatt of
generating capacity and in New Hampshire
about 4,300 uh megawatts of generating
capacity um first off we want to
underscore that we understand that
consumers in New Hampshire and in the
region throughout New England are
struggling with costs right now and we
also know that there is growing concern
regarding reliability and the resource
mix in the region Our concern is that
house bill 710 May well very well
exacerbate these issues and not
alleviate
them and we say this recognizing the
really exciting possibilities and
potential that advanced nuclear offers
and we understand the excitement that
some people have about it however House
Bill 710 would put New Hampshire's
consumers at Great risk for cost
overruns this is an emerging technology
and again one that shows great promise
but it's it's a technology that
currently would cost far more than what
we see in wholesale electricity markets
and the risk associated with whether or
not you should take the risk to invest
in it anyway really belongs with private
investors who do this all the time and
have that level of sophistication that
risk belongs with NE with them not with
captive rate paays it's really private
investors that should take on the risks
not the rate payers and allowing
utilities to take on their risk on
behalf of their customers has the
unintended consequence I think of
discouraging private investment why
would you want to take on the risk to
develop one of these if you know that
the local utility has that edge on you
in terms of their financing and we also
think it's a good moment to remember
that some of the consistent core goals
of the Department of energy State energy
strategy say that government
intervention in energy markets should be
limited justifiable and Technology
neutral
they should support a robust Market
selection of coste effective Energy
Solutions and they should generate
instate economic activity without
Reliance on permanent subsid
subsidization of energy we think that
there's wisdom in these goals we support
these goals we share these goals and we
think that utility ownership of advanced
nuclear power um is in conflict in in
with these goals uh but recognizing the
great excitement again that people have
regarding this resource we encourage New
Hampshire maybe to to revisit this
policy in a few years there are groups
in other parts of the country and in
Canada that are looking to do some pilot
projects with this maybe you can let
them go first and learn from any
mistakes and Lessons Learned I
questions okay questions for M
Connor representative Corman thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Miss Connor
it's always good to see you um you
mentioned reliability you had concern
about reliability but I didn't hear you
expand on that so this is your
opportunity oh I I you know I've been
following this committee for quite some
time and I I and I've been in some of
your hearings where people say they're
worried about where the resource mix is
going um we've made some comments along
those lines too that we're seeing a
number of power plants that we rely on
during peak hours ones that have stored
fuel for example that are retiring and
um we're seeing that the um
emergence of their Replacements are not
coming online as as quickly U because of
sighting issues and financing issues so
we see a lot of power plants retiring um
but we don't see new power plants coming
on as quickly and there are a myriad of
issues around it but I think that's
really at the core of I think what
people I know when I think about
reliability that's one of the things I
think about um but I think also people
have other concerns but more the
distribution level like storm resilience
and things like
that follow up thank you I'm sorry I
still don't understand understand what
that's that has to do with utilities
owning Advanced nuclear oh um and so
what I'm trying to say is I focused on
the cost overruns largely because I
represent you uh generators that live
and die in the markets and so anything
that's why I focused on on the markets
in the financial aspect if you want
private investors to the reliability
question if you want to have private
investors putting their private Capital
into New Hampshire and New England they
should feel like they're is a Level
Playing Field and if you allow utility
ownership that could undermine some of
that
confidence why would you put all that
money on the line if you know that
another utility could do that and have a
a very steady uh Revenue
questions seeing none thank you Miss
Connors thank
you next up will be Michael Lata from
eversource
thank
you good afternoon uh for the record
Michael Lata representing eversource
energy thank you for the opportunity to
testify before you this
afternoon um just want to share a few
thoughts and comments on the bill uh
first and foremost uh we definitely
appreciate the sponsor's goal goal to
look at creative uh options to develop
additional energy resources uh it's been
long discussed uh projections of
increased load due to electrification as
well as uh data centers driven by uh
artificial intelligence uh driving the
need for additional resources to meet
the that projected growth um just want
to say straight off uh that eversource
has no plans to develop nuclear
Generation Um but we do report uh
certainly as you've heard me testify in
the past uh efforts by the state to
increase electri increase energy Supply
uh and improve affordability um as I
think the committee is well aware uh
small modular reactor technology is at
its very early stages of
commercialization um and certainly
there's a long way to go before any of
these uh uh generation resources would
be
uh
cost come down and cost to a point where
it would be uh make sense for a utility
to to do an investment uh in them uh as
has been pointed out I would just say
that any development by uh a utility to
use the authority under this bill um
would have to get approval of the Public
Utilities Commission uh under the 374 G
process which uh as noted previously is
is a rather High bar and only one
utility has been successful uh in
utilizing that authority to date uh and
as has been pointed out by the
department of energy uh that's somewhat
of a a
pre-authorization uh then the project
would have to be constructed and the
utility would have to come back to the
Public Utilities Commission to seek cost
recovery of the cost associated with
that construction and presumably if
there is a Delta between the estimated
costs uh prior to constru ction and the
actual built costs uh those would be
costs that are are uh at risk of being
found to be imprudent um the the real
thrust of uh my testimony was to
recommend if the committee is moving
forward with this bill uh to strike uh
section two of the bill that would
require utilities to offer um Advanced
nuclear rate options but uh I did hear
the the bill sponsor say that uh he
intends to bring forth amendment to do
that we think that that would be very
helpful um Advanced nuclear uh options
are are certainly different than
renewable options in terms of how
utilities would be able to comply and
procure that um with that I'd be happy
to answer any questions the committee
may
have questions for Mr Lata
representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr LC so if the actual cost then
exceed those projected costs and the Pu
doesn't approve those higher than
expected costs do th does that then
become a stranded cost no that would be
uh the utilities is at risk for
disallowance of those costs they would
be found imprudent and the shareholders
would have to to make up that difference
essentially the Pu would not be
approving the cost recovery of those
expenses represent ative McGee thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr Lata my
question is around the changes that
would uh sort of backtrack a bit on the
deregulation and the removal of
utilities participating in this the
generation market so the question
basically is what kind of an effect you
think it would have on the competitive
Supply Market which I think is just sort
of starting to get to a place where
competition is actually playing in the
region
uh if if the utilities were allowed to
invest in
uh in more expensive uh forms of energy
uh and recover those monies or a good
portion of them from the rate payer what
what kind of an effect do you think that
would have on the competitive market
which we were trying to initiate when we
passed deregulation sure I I I think it
would depend on
um the how the utility would
utilize the output of the generation and
certainly when you had mentioned that it
would be uh very expensive I I think a
prudent utility would not propose
something that would be uh more
expensive and a uh you know
functioning uh Public Utilities
Commission went ought approve the cost
recovery if it was um uneconomic uh but
in terms of how it might impact the
competitive market if the utility were
to uh to construct this they could use
the output to serve uh their customers
or they could use the output to Simply
bid into the competitive market and then
customers would receive the benefit of
the revenues of those sales so it it
depends on how the utility were to
structure that and as was discussed on a
on your bill representative you know
that uh the impacts of utility
investments in distributed energy
resources is one criteria that the
commission uh has to consider when
evaluating whether to approve um these
Investments follow up the followup
question would just be then where would
we be in terms of deregulation if we did
this because I I think the the exception
that currently exists in law that's
referenced in this bill where uh where
renewable generation resides saying that
there's a benefit to having people
adding local sustainable energy which
also has has no cost as it goes forward
in terms of uh the generation itself
right so it provides uh a lower impact
on costs um what does it do I guess I'm
just trying to figure out what it does
to our attempt at deregulation it was
the same point that the doe brought up
right they said this will kind of undo
the purpose of the regulation which is
to deregulate the utilities from
participating in large scale generation
I'll say
yeah
certainly efforts and initiatives to
allow utility ownership of
generation is a step back from Full
electric restructuring I think that's
just a fair statement thank
you representative Harrington thank you
thank you for taking my question there's
been a lot of discussion here about
relative risk and you know you were
saying that if utility went to the Pu
and the costs weren't just and
reasonable that they wouldn't be
reimbursed for those costs which which
of course is true but I think it's a
little different with and we site for an
example let's say there's two projects
being built they're both
smrs uh and for whatever crazy reason a
small plane crashes into the
construction project in both of them
totally beyond the control of either the
independent Builder or the utility
building now the independent Builder is
going to eat 100% of their cost unless
they have insurance for small plane
crashes which I doubt they would uh on
the other hand if the utility was in
that situation they could go to the Pu
and said this was totally beyond our
control we had no problem we had no way
of knowing this was going to happen and
we should be reimbursed for those costs
isn't that the way the difference in
Risk is it's kind of an extreme example
but so under
that very hypothetical situation um you
know I I think it's the utility can try
to recover those costs uh obviously we
have
anti-ip law in New Hampshire that I
think would make it difficult for the
utility to do so but you know I can't
speak for the details of you know follow
that level of hypothetical yeah I'm this
would be after the fact it was built I'm
not talking
about making the case my point is I'm
trying to get is there at least there is
a a process with the utility could go
and maybe recover some of their cost
where the independent uh construct
dependent a builder of the generation
would have no option whatsoever they
would just have to eat the cost isn't
that correct I I I think that's fair the
utility would would likely seek to
costs representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um and thank you for being
here um so far we've we've done a dance
between pu doe State of New Hampshire
and the utilities for development of
projects
no one has mentioned furk yet um furk I
mean no nuclear project can be developed
without without FK saying so so how
would you imagine
FK and NRC oh I'm sorry NRC yeah how
would you imagine they play into this
dance so very much appreciate the
question and I I'll do my best to
respond uh you know with the asterisks
that I'm I'm not a subject matter expert
however um I I think what this bill is
dealing with is essentially the cost
recovery through um as a regulated
public utility of the construction of a
plant where entities like furk the NRC
uh would be involved in the the
licensing um if there's interstate
commerce involved you know a
transmission play here uh FK would be
involved but really this is this bill is
focus on cost recovery of construction
and then the treatment of the electric
output where there are other State uh
entities like the site evaluation
committee and federal entities that
would govern the the construction and
operation of of the ENT of the um you
know hypothetical small modular nuclear
reactor thank
you other question
questions thank you seeing none we'll
give uh the last word to Nick cof of the
hey good afternoon um again I'm Nick cof
of the conservation law Foundation
appreciate being here today um so
conservation law Foundation is neutral
on this bill um but I'm here today to
offer some suggestions on possible
improvements to the bill um I've handed
out written comments which provide more
detail about what I'm going to talk
about um now Advanced nuclear it may
present opportunities for the state um
but allowing utility ownership is a
fairly of advanced nuclear is a L large
departure from the state's restructuring
law um the overall purpose of the
restructuring law was to reduce costs
for consumers by harnessing competitive
markets um in pursuant to the
restructuring laws as has been mentioned
the utility sold off their um generation
assets and you know as has also been
pointed out there are currently only
narrow exceptions under um you the
state's public utility laws you know um
the restruction large preclusion of
utility ownership of generation
facilities um including for de as we've
talked about now that exception is much
narrower than what we're talking about
here so for de 5 megawatts 6% of
utilities cumulative load um you know
this is particularly for the facility
size this is much bigger so 90 megawatts
and 15% of utili cumulative load so it's
it's a much much larger um exception to
the um restructuring law in that sense
um and it also creates a much bigger
risk for rate
payers you as has been pointed out
utility would seek to rate rate base
those costs for a nuclear facility
recover those costs from a rate payer or
from the rate payers um which would
create substantial risks for rate payers
um you know and this is particularly a
big concern given that we don't know
what anr will cost at this point in
time um so I mean so a couple thoughts
on ways to improve the bill first off I
think it would be better to reduce the
the size that's in the bill you know the
90 megawatt facility and and 15% um
cumulative load thresholds that are in
the bill um to make them more in line
with the current exceptions for
de um and then another thing I want to
point out is that the bill is very
explicit in amending RSA
374 G4
but it does not its current draft amend
RSA 374 G5 which includes that the
criteria for PC approval of
deer um you know under the under the
current um under the current law under
G5 that just says de so the bill really
should amend RSA 374 G5 as well to make
sure that those criteria apply to the
apply to anr um
but I also want to suggest an even
better approach to utility
ownership um which would be utility
procurement of advanced nuclear
resources so already under RSA
f11 um utilities are permitted to issue
requests for
proposals um to procure energy from from
um you know various sources as long as
it's new or incremental and I think even
under that existing language that would
apply to advanc nuclear so you know as
as I read the current law already um you
the utilities can issue an
RFP which you know would would include
resources from Advanced nuclear um and
then relying on utility procurements
instead of utility ownership that would
really accomplish many of the same
purposes of this of this bill but
substantially reduce risks to raid
payers um so that's really something for
the committee to consider here and I
think you could accomplish that with
very very minimal you know if if any
amendments to um RS RSA
374 um f11 the procurement statute um so
yeah and some you know I recommend
passes the bill only if um some of these
changes are made and happy to take any
you okay thank you uh questions
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr coff for taking my
question um
so you you've come up with a sort of a
workaround uh which addresses my earlier
question about putting the utilities
back in the generation business right so
that would be a way for them to
procure uh available energy or make
people aware that they would be willing
to procure that energy uh so it might
solve the same problem but it would not
put the rate payers at risk is that what
you're yeah I correct I mean there' be
substantially less risk I mean there's
some risk for procurement because you
basically have a long-term contract
saying we're going to purchase you know
energy for X number of years and so that
does create some risk but you don't have
the same level of risk as you do with
ownership which you know if if the you
know if there's cost overruns basically
rate pairs on the hook for that um
yeah appreciate
it representative Harrington has a
question yeah just follow up on that
issue um let's just say for whatever
reason somehow it's 10 years from now
and someone builds a nuclear reactor a
new one in New Hampshire SMR at 150
megaw is there anything in the law that
would prohibit any new uh New Hampshire
utilities from negotiating a PPA with
that uh particular company if indeed it
was a good deal and they could bring it
to the Pu and the Pu approved it um I
mean I I don't think so I mean I think
RSA 374 f11 allows that you know
provides that Authority I would note
that with that existing statute set to
sunset in um June of this year so you
may wish to amend that you know push
that push that date out but um yeah I
mean generally procurements have been
allowed in the past and you know that's
something that U many utilities do in
other states okay follow up followup
yeah I guess my point I'm going to try
to get across here whether it was a a
gas fired plant a offshore wind plant a
uh to onshore wind um or a nuclear plant
the utility has the ability to go out
and negotiate a PPA that's in the best
interest of the customers they don't
need any additional leg legislation to
do that do they yeah absolutely okay
thank
you representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being
here uh okay I'm going to try to set up
this scenario if if utilities are
allowed to procure their their energy
from these nuclear um
facilities might that lead to many large
nuclear facilities located in New
Hampshire for profit obviously and if so
are there any concerns about the number
of nuclear facilities that could result
because of this should there be
restrictions or something like that I
mean are you saying that this is going
to encourage more you know more um
Advanced nuclear facilities being cited
here is that is that the question that's
my concern that's your concern yes um I
I certainly think you know it could
happen at some point I mean as as ever
sources said um you know they don't have
any plans to develop um Advanced nuclear
at this point in time but I mean I think
you know depending on circumstances
there there could be an effort to site
more anr anr here in the future sure
thank
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you Mr
crov and I'm going to close the public
hearing on H H b710 FN and immediately
we'll open in a public hearing on HB 764
FN and I'll call Representative Kelly
Penza to introduce this legislation to
us a question for the chair if I could
yes representative parshall thank you so
much do we have numbers for the online
testimony submissions on that last
bill I'll ask representative PL if he
good afternoon representative prenza
welcome back thank you Mr chair um for
the record uh representative Kelly Penza
straford District
19 um I'm here today to introduce um HB
764 uh I hope you've all received the
amendment um I put this amendment in I
don't know week and a half two weeks ago
after I saw the fiscal note that came
back um so that it has literally the
bill has changed so it has cut out um
that entire portion of the bill um which
makes this uh definitely easier and more
palatable to everyone um we had a bill
that was introduced uh I was a
co-sponsor of last session and um it was
very extensive this bill is is pretty
much quite simple it does um it does a
couple different things so currently
which um you should have received this
as well chapter 12f which is a current
statute has a weather modification
experimentation um statute it's called
12f so it repeals 12f and it puts the
most important part of
12f which uh representative Judy Aon had
done an amendment to in um in 2021 and
it puts it into um its own kind of uh
part of this bill where it actually
prohibits Geon jering um in case of of
course there was severe drought um and
then there would be um you know a
declaration of a national emergency or a
Statewide emergency and then of course
the governor would have um access to be
able to do that if we were in that
severe and it gives all the steps um
which are similar to of what's in this
chapter 12f about what would take place
if we did uh fall into a severe drought
and we needed to um have cloud seating
efforts in New
Hampshire the other part of the bill is
basically um prohibiting uh
geoengineering weather
modification
um the terms Sai and SRM which is solar
radiation modification and Strat uh
stratospheric air
injection um and that we're Banning um
in a sense or prohibiting those um those
in New Hampshire there last year I
gave unbelievable amounts of follow-up
testimony uh 12-page document that took
me hundreds of hours going back I only
went actually back to um 1965 I could
have gone back to the 1930s that talked
about um all different levels of
administrations that have been involved
in this um how it's been a global effort
from the UN to um you know the um the
weather Enterprise and all of this and
so just so we could have some background
on this um on this whole topic
um folks in New Hampshire have not
consented to this um and the piece of
the bill here where it has a involvement
of
now would be um and I can show you the
document that has about 35 different
federal agencies um that would be
notified and I have all of the
background um facts from all the
different government set websites but
these are all of the ones right now it's
on line on the uh Amendment page two
line 30 all the way to um line
um 37 and then on page three line one to
line 17 that would be contacted if this
bill uh is fortunate enough to um make
it to the end and um that they would be
contacted that New Hampshire prohibits
this uh type of weather um
modification and that's pretty much
um the whole bill at this point there is
um there really shouldn't be uh a fiscal
note on it um because of the Amendment
and um
and uh part of the there was a concern
about the cloud seating piece and and
the that was the biggest concern that I
um that I received um from fellow
Representatives fellow co-sponsors of
the bill and so we took care of that
specifically in all of the text here uh
in regards if there was any sort of
State emergency and um I'm open up for
thank you representative for introducing
that
legislation questions for representative
patena representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question I've just I'm
looking on page two of the bill on line
29 maybe I'm just missing something here
but it says and the penalties for
violating such
prohibitions where do I find the
penalties there's no penalties are you
in the do you have the amendment I have
the amendment uh
page two line 29 stats geoengineering is
prohibited and the penalties for
violating such prohibitions and I'm
trying to find where the penalties are
in the bill I
don't line 29 page two oh page two yeah
right before he starts listing all the
agencies that's just a mistake from from
OS that it just needs to be wiped out of
there there are no there are no
penalties so all right so that cles out
that's they they removed everything that
was in front of that so that's why all
right thank you she just that would be
um that would be taken out so basically
it should it should read the
commissioner of the Department of
Environmental Services shall within 30
days of the effective date of the
section provide notice to the following
entities that geoengineering is
prohibited in New Hampshire bam and then
it would go 30 to 37 and then on page
questions well seeing none I guess I'll
thank you for introducing this
representative
PL thank you chair thank you represent
Pensa reading this
over it says the
state well you already read
it considering
these alleged chemicals dispersions of
materials all you're asking or
telling I got to put this in a
question what benefit would it have to
us if it's being done now to allow these
chemicals or any chemicals to be
dispersed what is the a positive reason
there's actually no positive reason and
if uh if this committee would like
because of of course there's new
Representatives on this committee I'd be
happy to submit um the 12-page document
that I had put together I could cut out
specifically um those uh those chemicals
from and I can read them off here um
that cause a lot of problems respiratory
problems um so from aluminum to sulfur
oxide there's a whole slew of them that
cause um some problems we have had some
private citizens and uh I've received
that have done this on their own and um
where they have tested um the rainwater
um in local labs for you know some of
these um entities that wouldn't be from
um acid rain and um so a gentleman in
Salem and a Gentleman up North so but
those of course are anecdotal or
whatever but um and I also should also
say that um Tennessee has passed similar
legislation
and uh they did that last year as well
as Florida is very close right now um to
thing okay further questions
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Venza for coming back with the an
improved Bill and it looks like you've
you know tried to work through all the
issues my question uh has to do with
there's a number of references to the
Department of Environmental Services and
I see a representative from Dees here
today did you speak with Dees about any
of the conclusions that you've made here
or any of the activities that you will
be asking them to undertake during the
you know the research for the bill I
have um and he's going and he's here he
has the amended version of it um you
know their concern was
um when it was in its previous version
was the tracking or the tracing and of
that and and of course a big huge line
item um monetarily as well so that has
all been removed um it's very easy for
the Department to send a certified
letter to those government agencies and
that's all we're asking for at this
point is a
notice a notice basically saying New
Hampshire has passed this law
followup follow up I think he has to
approve the followup but thank you um so
on page two section three line 15 it
says the Department of Environmental
Services shall maintain oversight of all
cloud seeding activities to ensure
compliance with regulations and to
assess the effectiveness of cloud
seeding operations that sounds like more
than just sending a letter it sounds
like they actually have to have no
that's that has to do with uh the if
there's an emergency and cloud seating
is necessary okay that doesn't have
anything to do that has to do with
basically taking 12 F and putting it
into the declared state of emergency if
there's a catastrophic drought that has
everything to do with that which they
would be part of if we needed to have
cloud seating it doesn't have anything
to do with
the so that L that line I'm referring to
is section three and that you're saying
that that's under a state of emergency
piece yes if you if you read 125 c23
exception for cloud seaing weather
modification in caseine of of
catastrophic drought you have one a b c
and d two and then you have three okay
cool okay additional questions Vice
chair Thomas as one thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so just
to be clear as I'm reading through your
Amendment uh it appears that uh because
of what's on the first page of line
starting on uh line 30 that the
amendment basically says there will be
no geoengineering activities weather
modification cloud seeding aerosol
injection none
whatsoever not that you're asking for
permission um or anything it just says
there'll be none and the only exception
would be if it's uh catastrophic drought
declared by the governor by way of
several state agencies is is that the in
yes follow follow
up and so um this basically says that
there's no notification there uh this is
not saying first you have to notify us
or first you have to get a permit or
anything like that it's a straight um
there is no other option the state would
have no choice if this bill if this
amendment was a passed like this
correct um correct but no one ever
consented to um weather modification
experimentation in section 12f and if
that's something that um the state wants
to do I mean our constitution our New
Hampshire Constitution uh as well as our
US Constitution is very clear that you
need to have consent of the people um
before you're experimenting anything on
them and we never gave that kind of
consent so in regards with um exemption
for cloud seeding in a case of
catastrophic drought as you can see um
that would be in an extreme uh
circumstance and there is notification
to all of um you know the entire State
all of the constituents as well as then
the it's mon monitored of course from
the Department of Environmental Services
um you have to give consent before you
decide you're doing any sort of
experimentation on anyone
thanks additional questions
representative
Harrington yeah I just wanted to follow
up on this because as I read this now
and maybe I'm missing something but it
it gives the prohibition there on the
bottom of page one on line 30 no person
shall engage in so forth so forth and so
on so let's say I observe someone
engaging in this or I take some test
when I see oh there's somebody
depositing something out of the sky I
collect samples find out it's F somehow
qualifies under this as being illegal
there apparently then is nothing I can
do about it I just say I've documented
illegal working happenings but there's
no recourse so I don't understand what
it
accomplishes well it actually
accomplishes a lot so first we are
repealing something that gave that gave
uh a state Authority when they never had
the authority because they never had
consent of the people so that's very
important and two um in the new
Administration in the federal
Administration there's been a lot of
discussion about this there's been a ton
of media about it um we're most likely
going to see uh an executive order about
this um coming down the pike this is
these are federal agencies NOS um that
it's very hard to control so the bill
that I proposed or that was proposed
last session um tried to get a way we
could track and people could um people
could um you know whatever put in
complaints and all of that and there
just isn't a pathway and there isn't a
pathway for Dees to do it because it
cost it'll cost a million dollars so
this is step one this is um basically
repealing something that we never
consented to saying that it and it's
exactly the same bill just so you know
in Tennessee There's No enforcement
mechanism it pretty much makes the
statement that it's not allowed in our
state and so that's where we're
basically putting the stake in the
ground and we're saying that it's not
allowed and all of those agencies are
going to get notified that are known to
do weather modification GE engineering
SI SRM and it's it's step one and um
because of what's going to be happening
I on I believe within the next two
months on the federal side I think it
would be really good for New Hampshire
to have this in place to say we don't
consent
representative uh Wendy Thomas thank you
Mr chair um and thank you for presenting
this bill um I just am trying to figure
out the timeline in on page two here so
cloud seating is a is allowed if the
governor establishes a state of
emergency and then on line 12 it says
prior to cloud seeding you have to do
this whole thorough Environmental
review doesn't that defeat um declaring
a state of emergency so so is it the
state of emergency and then we go to a
review or are they doing a constant
review prior to declaring a state of
emergency thank you so I I would have to
say that this was done with the lawyer
in OS and it was specific so for example
um there's a c catastrophic drought it's
not as if cloud seating would happen
within you know 2 days from that the
governor is not a scientist doesn't work
for the Department of Environmental
Services is not a hydrogeologist or any
of those things so they would say they
would put forward an emergency saying
that we need cloud seating and then of
course the department would have to be
able to provide the data that that's
this basically is telling the people the
state shall conduct a thorough
environmental review assessing potential
risks and benefits and ensuring that the
activities will not result in harm to
the environment public health or
Wildlife that's part of it so the the um
the state of emergency for a
catastrophic drought and saying that we
the governor believes that cloud seating
is necessary there still has to be SE
steps that would take place it's just
like anything else it's not as if okay
take out the planes it's going to happen
tomorrow so this is just it's basically
a um an approach that involves not only
the entity of the stakeholders of the
state the Department of Environmental
Services but also the consent of the
people thank
you further questions representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative patens to bringing this
bill um I just have a concern about the
the kind of the implicit notion behind
this that that somehow the clouds in New
Hampshire just stay right above us what
if this concept caught on and say the
state of Vermont or the state of Maine
declares an emergency drought and they
want to seed their clouds but the clouds
are coming from the south or they're
coming from the East they would have to
fly over the state of New Hampshire to
seed their clouds or or I mean is that
foresee um maybe I I I don't know I'm
most of the time when um cloud seating
is happening it's not necessarily um
so if you've ever if you ever watched a
video of the planes that are doing that
they're not like following clouds and
doing it like that it's basically over a
certain geographical area uh I can send
you a wonderful video that was done in
Colorado that shows that so it's it's
specific around an area it's not as if
they're following the clouds basically
when the um when the chemicals or
whatever is released um it it creates a
cloud cover it actually and then clouds
form around that you know um injection
atmosphere representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
Penza for indulging me I went and looked
up uh chapter F12 which is our current
statute on weather modification
experimentation which I know you're
quite familiar with and I guess what my
concern is is uh the statute that we
have on the books for weather
modification
experimentation already talks about the
Departments and the state and the
governor uh and the executive Council
being
involved um in any discussions around
how to pay for or to undertake any type
of uh weather
modification um that that might require
cooperation with the federal government
which is what we see in other states
that we know um have had cloud seating
programs say to get rain for droughts
like out in California and that kind of
thing um and uh so the section one talks
about that piece of sort of like who's
involved and these are all elected
people so it's not like people don't
have any say because these are
Representatives we have a representative
government but section two says that two
months prior to the presentation to the
governor executive
Council uh for engagement in experiment
mention or
techniques um the department or agency
of State participating in such
engagement or experimentation shall do
the following and then they have public
notice in at least four papers which is
similar to language that you have in
your bill so they're required to not
only notify the public they're also
required to disclose to the public the
chemical compounds and technologies that
will be used in the proposed weather
modification in the state and the
effects of the programs or
experimentations on human health
Wildlife wildlife habitats that may be
affected and the sources of funding to
perform such programs so it sounds like
the existing statute that you propose to
eliminate actually has a lot of valuable
things in it um It also says under C of
that statute solicit public input
regarding the proposed weather
modification program or experimentation
so I don't understand why you want to
eliminate this statute and you think
that this statute is preferable is it
because it's a Prohibition
um actually pretty much everything
that's in that statute is in um my
Amendment um because it's still it's
there is
no it there's no consent in here it's
basically um and by the way it's never
happened um so if there has been any
sort of experimentation that's happened
um most people aren't even familiar with
this statute I have talked to um my
executive counselor actually and another
executive counselor that they're not
they weren't even familiar with this at
all it was kind of just done in placed
and only um representative Aaron um felt
that she's the one that added those
other notifications in there they didn't
they didn't have anything in there
before and that was in
2021 um the piece that's missing is
consent and so um any department or
agency of the state may with approval of
the governor and Council and within the
limits of funds blah blah blah basically
says that you can do it and that's the
that's where um that's where the
prohibition is coming in because of that
so if there is a need for um cloud
seating in the case of and that's really
the only piece of weather modification
that would be something that is known
um um it's a known entity it's been
going on for decades and um in then it's
included in here so yeah there doesn't
we never consented to be um guinea pigs
for any sort of weather modification
that's why this needs to be removed and
questions representative
the
question
Banning experimentation cloud seeding
any dispersion over New Hampshire if it
needs to be
done is not
in I don't want to use the
opinion is the other New England states
environment the same as New Hampshire
that they can do it there it's not like
they're stopping their experimentation
just not over New
Hampshire yeah not every state and I can
if the committee wants to have that not
every state has um We're The Unlucky
state that has a weather modification
experimentation uh statute uh I don't
believe that Vermont does but um it
really doesn't matter like I said
Tennessee passed it for Tennessee
Florida's about to pass it for Florida
if you know Vermont wants to perform
weather modification experiments or
cloud seeding or Maine or Massachusetts
they're welcome to do it so um this is
basically just saying um leave New
Hampshire B and um and there's not any
um all of the all of the chemicals that
are in every bit of these um the
dispersements they're not all by plane
they are by drone they are by uh
balloons they also are by ships that um
eject them in there and I mean I I don't
there's people that are on this
committee that should remember I mean I
sent you um every bit of information
it's been going on for a very very long
time there's lots of concerns
internationally um Mexico actually
banned this specifically um because they
were letting off balloons to block the
sun um and so this isn't you know this
isn't some um madeup thing it's been
going on for a long time in the 1930s
they used it in the military um to
create because they knew um they could
do that in Wartime situations and so
we've had the technology for a long time
I don't know if you guys are familiar
with chaff um you can actually see chaff
on um meteorologist notice but
definitely out on the coast so uh it's
very familiar in California for example
um where it it looks very different so
if you see if you're looking a um on a
weather report and you can see the color
they know because it's basically it's
got heavy metals in it which is put on
there that's a um chaff is a military
term I put that in my documentation so
there's a lot of stuff that's not good
it's not good for the soil it's not good
for people uh it's not good for
respiratory things it's not good for our
environment um you know I'm on
environment and agriculture I wish this
bill came to our committee um because I
think people are more aware of it there
um I've been receiving messages from
people all over the country um I have
talked to reps in South Carolina North
Carolina New York all of these reps are
putting in similar legislation and like
I said um the federal government right
now is looking at this because they've
they've um really um not paid attention
to this and there's a lot of people
making a lot of money on on you know
just trying to either whether it be
block the Sun or um or create um certain
weather episodes because everything goes
into um when we try to play God
everything goes into a certain thing you
affect one thing there's a there's a
there's
a an effect a you know a triple down
effect or a trickle down effect for
everything else and that's why I believe
that this is this is the way to do it uh
it won't be a cost to anyone in the
state and um and since you know
supposedly they haven't been doing other
modification experimentation um because
we haven't heard of it um in regards
with that there should be no problem in
passing this prohibition on it
especially since we know it's going to
be coming from up top very soon in the
next couple
months okay further
questions seeing none thank you
representative for introducing this
legislation let's hear next from New
Hampshire Dees I'll call on Mike
Fitzgerald
Fitzgerald members of the committee
Michael Fitzgerald assistant director of
the air Resources Division Department of
Environmental
Services uh I want to thank
representative Penza for reaching out to
us this afternoon and providing us with
a copy of the amendment um so I will
address most of my remarks to the uh to
the potential Amendment uh assuming that
that's um something that the committee
is going to consider uh we did provide a
fiscal note on the original Bill and as
representative poent indicated it would
have required significant resources so
um uh in and I have only had the
amendment for an hour and I've had two
other hearings that I've been in so uh
I'm just just beginning to absorb it but
uh um it does seem as representative
Penza stated to eliminate a significant
amount of the the uh effort and
resources that would have been required
of the department in the original bill
um I do note that uh page as was noted
previously page two line 12 does say the
state shall conduct a thorough
environmental review I'm not sure who
the state is what who would be
responsible but I assume that would be
something that the under this situation
of
emergency um uh for allowing cloud
seating that um the governor would make
some some sort of designation
um and I don't know what kind of
resources would be necessary to do that
but it's not directed at at our
department specifically so um I'm just
just noting that um section three uh
again I think it's rather unlikely um we
don't see a lot of uh cloud seating to
the best of my knowledge uh here I'm not
addressing the other aspects that
representative Potenza uh bill the
amendment um we're addressing but uh
cloud seating for weather modification
um when and specifically to address
drought um we're we're not aware of New
Hampshire has been in in serious drought
conditions over the past several years a
number of times there are specific
requirements I think it's in St RSA 485
but I'm not uh the drought expert that's
our Water Division I'm I'm with the air
division um there are some specific
requirements for the governor in in
addressing draw emergencies and so on um
so uh that uh should probably be be
looked at as well um as far as the
notice of prohibition uh I don't see
again representative penzo stated
correctly that it does not seem
particularly burdensome or honorous to
us um it's just a matter of of uh draft
drafting a letter and sending it out to
the agencies required here so um
I would note that uh uh this is an issue
that is of concern to many citizens we
do get a lot of complaints um we do get
a lot of calls and concerns and um um
again the department has no particular
authority to address uh these types of
emissions right now um but again and
this this bill would not um uh put that
Authority upon us uh the the amendment
as I understand it would no longer put
that upon us
um so uh I think that's basically all of
my comments I'd be happy to address any
questions uh if
they're and I also have uh Dave Healey
with us who's our chief scientist and
meteorologist um again we don't have a
lot of familiarity with this type of
work but um Dave is here and if there
are questions I might ask him to come up
and answer help us I'm
sorry okay questions for Mr Fitzgerald
Vice jar Thomas thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question more
Curious and since you do have air in
your name I'll ask you this uh this
question how do you know what the
maximum altitude would be for cloud
seeding to be effective at all and would
that still be within the New Hampshire
airspace uh well if you're referring to
Aaron my name as Airhead maybe
then um but uh uh no I don't have any
particular familiarity with cloud
seeding procedures or or information
again RSA 12f is is not specific to our
department um currently so um I I I we
could certainly try to find some
information and get back to you on it
now representative Harrington has a
question thank you Mr chairman than for
take my question I guess uh you would
mention that you got a number of
complaints and phone calls on this I was
wondering how would you deal with a law
like this that says all this stuff is
prohibited and then they're going to say
okay what are you going to do about it
Mr uh air director you can to say we're
going to do absolutely nothing because
we have no authority to do anything is
that I just seems to set you up for the
Fall Guy it it it is a little uh a
little difficult but um I you know our
our response in these situations is
generally the RFA the rsa's that we uh
uh enforce and and carry out um we do
them with the authority that's provided
to us by the legislature so if the
legislature chose to Pro to approve an
RSA that had a a uh proabition on
something but no violation or whatever
that would be our answer is um we we yes
it is prohibited no we have no authority
to address it
further
questions seeing none I want to thank
you thank you next I'll call up did you
have one uh representative I was just
wondering if we could ask any questions
of the meteorologist since he has
expertise in the in the cloud realm
whereas Mr Fitzgerald is not an expert
that be permitted Mr Fitzgerald we uh
Dave you want to join us he brought him
along you know m loves company uh uh so
I don't is this to address this the
question about cloud seating and Heights
and so on yes I think that the
atmospheric stuff that's not your
specialty yeah I yeah I I would say and
I'll defer to Dave after but I would say
that
obviously activities that occur uh at
significant height 20 30,000 ft they
could occur in Ohio and those
uh those emissions we we regularly deal
with what's known as Air transport of of
pollutants from the Midwest um and so uh
that's why we have a monitoring station
on top of Mount Washington and a
monitoring station at the top of Pacman
adok to to measure those high level
emissions um but uh again Dave I don't
know if you have any familiarity with
cloud seeding or anything to to add
that yeah in well in the in the uh Rec
research that I did to to prepare for
for this hearing um and this is very
limited research I should say but I I
think I saw um altitudes of 12,000 to
13,000 ft for uh cloud seeding to be
effective but again that's just brief
research that I did to to try to get
ready for this meeting um but yeah Mike
is correct to just to build on his point
um you know Smoke Stacks from power
plants in the Ohio River Valley that are
you know a th000 or 2,000 ft hot tall
they release pollutants that can be
transported to our part of the country
currents followup I guess the question I
would have is then who is responsible
for that level of the atmosphere if if
we actually have people that are in
charge of various pieces because it
seems like that it's the authority that
I'm I'm wondering about just you can't
prohibit something like you say if a
smoke stack in Ohio is creating what's
happening in that band of the atmosphere
whose jurisdiction is
it well those types of sources um you
know they're regulated by the Clean Air
Act and then um the states also you know
Under the Umbrella of the Clean Air Act
enforce their own rules but
um but it's it's you know it's a state
federal partnership
how we regulate those types of emission
sources yeah I I would just add the uh
we regularly meet with uh with EPA and
with with other states we've had a
number of efforts um uh as I mentioned
the ozone transport region um and
various other um uh Clean Air Act
requirements but um we certainly can't
tell Ohio what to do but the EPA can can
tell them and and the Clean Air Act does
have Provisions that require states to
address Interstate transport of
pollutants uh and so we work very
carefully with the EPA region and with
the EPA on a national basis in in how to
address emissions coming into our state
shell thank you Mr
chair I guess my question
is under what conditions do you need to
have for cloud seating to work and in
the drought we frequently have the
conditions that would allow cloud
work yeah again um cloud seating is is
not just it's not in the air resources
um I I know and I know those activities
go on um and there's nothing new about
cloud seeding and um it does go on in
other parts of the world and I think uh
West you know States out
west but um to my to my knowledge in the
research I I've done it it's not
something that happens frequently in
this part of the country so so I just
don't really have a good answer for that
question
probably all our knowledge is uh based
on cloud seating.com um
so we really don't have a have a lot of
expertise in that Arena followup please
followup I sort of tried to lead you
into into the situation where Cloud
seatings only going to work when you
have super saturated conditions in the
atmosphere if the air is not super
saturated you can seed all you want and
there will be no rain so that's what I
was looking for yeah do we have
typically those conditions of saturation
probably we don't know we don't know
yeah yeah we just just just don't have
the uh expertise on on cloud seating to
be able to give you a good answer we'd
be happy to take a look at that and get
back to you on something if we
can so I have a question if you look at
the last line of page one line 32 the
amendment or
um yes the amendment okay last line page
one yes it says that no person shall
engage in activities involving the
intentional release of polluting
emissions would that prevent for example
crop
dusting I believe there are uh specific
crop um dusting I believe the Department
of Agriculture has regulations um uh
regarding that uh we don't we would not
regulate crop dusting uh unless there
was a uh
uh toxic emissions uh that met the
requirements of um our statute uh the
toxics control act so um I know we have
had we've been in touch we've had
complaints about um pesticide spraying
applications at in on apple trees and in
large Orchards and so on and those
drifting into other areas and and we've
traditionally worked with the Department
of Agriculture on those to uh uh uh
address them under their uh
perview thank you yes further questions
Vice chair Thomas uh thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to piggy back off off
that last question for my clarification
I know is not your fielded but and then
am I to assume that if if crop dusting
is taking place I assume whatever is
used in the chemicals for crap dusting
is allowed under the EPA Air Act I would
think uh and if if that's true then they
would not be considered pollutants and
would not uh come under this bill if was
passed I would certainly tend to agree
with that that if uh that if EPA had
approved them as under the pesticide uh
control uh act and um uh then uh it's
it's you know probably an activity that
is would not be regulated by us under
the Clean Air Act
but New Hampshire does have its own
toxic Control Act
that
um you know is is is a separate
requirement so it's possible that
something could be approved by EPA but
it's subject to our toxic Control Act um
and again this is a gray area because
our our Act is generally um aimed at
stationary sources um power plants and
the chemical Manufacturing facilities
that sort of thing um we don't have a
lot of authority to the best of my
knowledge to regulate emissions from
aircraft or you know uh pesticide
spraying that sort of thing um we we'd
have to work closely with the Department
of Agriculture to ensure that there was
um you know joint um control appropriate
joint
control okay additional questions
sing none I'll thank you thank you very
much and invite Steven KF to come talk
KF press the red button
please thank you good to see you all
again I passed out my resume again so
you know my credentials and the audience
knows them
um U my credentials as a toxicologist
I'm currently retired from a long career
as a risk assessor evaluating impacts to
human and ecological Health my job was
essentially to determine the relative
risks of industrial missions on human
health and Wildlife and I have sampled
and evaluated all types of environmental
media and I worked in many states and
with many types of state and federal
Regulatory Agencies
I'm here to strongly support HP 764 I
was made aware of this issue when I
retired in
2019 about four out of seven days every
week I look up to see plumes of micro
and nanop particulates streaking across
the sky behind all different types of
high altitude
aircraft these plumes start out looking
quite sharp and defined like
contrails but then they persist
gradually diffusing out horizontally
across the sky as they hygroscopically
absorb more and more water vapor which
is what cloud seeding normally does by
the end of the day just like clockwork
the sun is blotted out by a thick Haze
more often than not the end result will
be an entirely overcast sky or Worse It
Will Rain the following day now some of
you may be skeptical about this but I
would encourage you to not only look up
but to look up throughout the day and
watch the progression of these plumes
how do we know these are not contrails
first you will see many of these plumes
stop and start kind of like Morse code
you will not see this staggered pattern
if it was normal jet exhaust second I
have videotaped aircraft at similar
altitudes one with a normal contrail
which disappears as fast as it is formed
but another alongside it with a
persistent geoengineered
plume which then evolves into a thick
lateral Cloud third I can show you many
photographs in which these plumes Will
Rain Down visible Trails of particulates
a phenomenon which I call Feathering
fourth there are thousands of photos and
videos all over the Internet which shows
Skies as a virtual checkerboard of
persistent aircraft plumes even if you
don't believe this is a true phenomenon
should normal air traffic result in 90%
of our incident sunlight to be blocked
out for the majority of each day I'm 71
years old and I can tell you with 100%
confidence that normal air traffic never
ended up destroying a sunny day on so
many occasions some of you might
remember deep blue skies as well as
bright cottony white cumulous clouds
which are not seen anymore since I have
retired I have sunk over $5,000 into
buying an advanced dark field microscope
I have spent $2,000 to become certified
as a certified live blood analyst and
I'm about to purchase a very expensive
ICP Mass spectrometer which can measure
very minute concentrations of met and
water now why would I do this because
since retirement I have been beyond
shocked to find out that the toxic
metals and chemicals we are seeing rain
down from the sky which have never been
seen in precipitation throughout my long
career aluminum barium stonum those type
of metals are also showing up in our
blood in fact it's even worse than that
it is truly orwellian to say this but we
are also starting to see what what are
known as self assembling nanotchnology
techology not only in human blood but
this technology is also seen in the
blood of wildlife squirrels rabbits deer
dogs cats you name it our surface soil
surface water soil and most Foods also
contain these visible structures now
being an expert in sampling and Analysis
I can tell you with certainty that the
level of contamination in a human or an
animal is always directly proportional
to the proximity to that Source
consequently since almost all
environment Al media are
contaminated the only possible source
for this contamination is from
geoengineering activities which has been
going on since the 1960s probably
earlier than that in fact there are many
scientific papers that show direct
correlations between the adulteration of
the atmosphere and contamination in
humans and
Wildlife and that is my testimony for
today I appreciate you listening and
your time and I just encourage you all
to look up more often more frequently
and I'll take any questions questions
for Mr
Club representative
kapan thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr K for coming in um I am curious about
your data on what you call the
self-replicating nanotechnology or self
something nanotechnology where where
where can we see that or where is that I
would direct you to so I'm a member of
Dr David David Nixon's micronauts Group
which is an international microscopy
group I would direct you to Dr David ni
Nixon's website uh Dr Anna milal Shia is
um on her substack is um doing
tremendous work just mindboggling work
showing uh these uh self assembling
particles
um uh there are a bunch of other
substacks uh you could go to
geoengineering watch. .org uh I'm not
sure they they would have that but and
you know if you wanted to talk offline
I'd be happy
to you could come down to my house I
could sit you down for a blood sampling
analysis and maybe even show show them
blood I'll give you the I'll give you
the blood sampling analysis for
free thank
glub well I guess there's no more thank
you sir for giving us your perspective
next up is Melissa white of
Peterboro just put money in the meter so
if you can go to the next one oh okay
next up is Rick Fazio of the business
Association good afternoon everyone uh
ch Vose Vice chair Thomas and committee
members for the record I'm Rick Fabrizio
uh senior director of advocacy and
public affairs for the business and
industry Association New Hampshire
Statewide Chamber of Commerce just uh
learned of the amendment earlier this
afternoon um we were opposed to the
original version because of the
inclusion of electromagnetic radio
frequency and micro microwave radiation
with the removal of that we would go to
a neutral position but I thought it was
important to state that as fact in case
in any part of the process a move was
made to restore references to the
electromagnetic radio frequency and
microwave radiation I'm happy to take or
try to answer any questions you might
have
so questions for Mr
fio representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr FAO for being here
um I you submitted testimony which I
glanced over briefly so I understand
that your exceptions were based on um is
it Cellular use of there might be some
overlap with existing technologies that
the electromagnetic radio frequency is
primarily used for wireless communic
telecommunications which actually
includes in certain cases television
radio wireless cell service um as well
Communications additional questions
representative Matson thank you Mr
Speaker um vice sh chair sorry um you
said that you know a little bit about
the cloud seeding can you tell me what
altitude they usually I I I certainly
did not oh sorry so I was just wondering
do you have any idea what altitude they
usually do this Cloud SE in hearing the
references someone said 12 to 13,000 ft
while someone else had mentioned perhaps
as high as 30 35,000 ft and had made
that point that at that height you start
to you know if you did it here at 30,000
ft it might be off the coast but no I
just had really uh looked up that um
weather
modification uh does not use radio
frequencies and and certainly not D in
additional
questions seeing none thank you Mr faio
Peterboro hi there thank you for having
us today uh my name is Melissa white I
live in Peterboro um I appreciate the
opportunity to discuss hb76 for with you
excuse me for being out of breath I just
had to feed my meter um and thank you
representative Penza for this great bill
um so couple things um I know that um
you already read the statutory or the
stat the the um legal EAS of the weather
modification
experimentation um Bill U or law 12- F1
um but it says any department or agency
of the state May with the approval of
the governor and Council and within the
limits of appropriated funds or by means
of gifts donations or grants engage in
and within the limits of appropriated
wait sorry I read that part undertake
experimentation in the techniques and
methods for weather modification and may
cooperate therein in the federal
government with authorized agencies of
other states and with interested persons
and organ
organizations so basically it's saying
that any interested party can undertake
an experiment ation in the techniques
and and methods for weather
modifications so even if you think it's
not happening now you can see again from
the documents Federal documents that um
you have been given by representative
Penza or she will give you if you
haven't received them already that it
will happen in the future because state
law allows it and because of that state
law 12- F1 must be repealed in its
entirety the last line of the law the
full law says that the state will
solicit public input regarding the
proposed me weather modification program
or experimentation
but soliciting public input is not the
same as
consent I host a social Media Group with
almost 2,000 members here in New
Hampshire not everyone's from New
Hampshire let's say 1500 are but not
that many people could come today
because we work and we received very
short notice of this hearing so I just
want you to know that none of us consent
to being experimented on and that is the
goal of
764 um and I also wanted to just point
out that um a lot of the questions seem
to be getting way off um way away from
the topic or or of the actual bill um so
the the goal of the bill is to
repeal uh 12- F1 and that's that's
pretty much it um and regarding the idea
that you know crop dusting could be
considered intentional release of
polluting emissions it says specifically
in those lines that it's in regards to
geoengineering that solar radiation
modification involving the intentional
release of of polluting emissions so
that is all connected to geoengineering
it's not about crop dusting or you know
other other activities so so
um again I'm a little rushed so I hope I
made sense and thank you all for your
time well thank you appreciate you
coming all the way from Peterboro
questions
for yes representative McGee Mr chairman
and thank you for being here and thank
you for making the time um I just wanted
to go back to 12f uh one because I see
where it says um at the end of section
one that there can be cooperation with
the federal government authorized
agencies or other states and with
interested persons and organizations but
that's not who's allowed to do this it's
the the beginning of the sentence says
any department or agency of the state
may with the approval of the governor
and councel so it isn't anybody that can
do this I mean the language is very
specific okay and so I just wanted to
clarify that because I don't I don't
think the intent of the people who put
this in place originally
um intended for it to be that anyone
could do this without Authority from the
state the governor the council so okay
yeah excellent thank you um yeah that's
there was no question so you don't have
to respond okay any uh questions for
Miss
White seeing none thank you very much
good afternoon and welcome to
St thank you for your time today I kind
of listening to everybody else didn't
write my own thing picking up the
slack we have a ring developing around
our equator because most of us believe
the Earth is round and that's the
centrifugal force moving these micro uh
Nano particles
to the center of our equator just with
kinetic energy so even though we don't
see it linger here it still hangs out
there and it is blotting out the sun
permanently with a ring like
Saturn so this is we're going to be
accountable to other countries and
Nations and New Hampshire going along
with it puts their Neco on that line
saying well we agree with it cuz we're
letting it happen here too so we want to
quickly remove ourselves from
cooperating with any of this because
it's genocide if you didn't know I know
people keep saying things like burum
salts but you got to understand that is
10,000 times more toxic than lead and
you're breathing it all right now the
stuff in this the nanop particles
actually cross your brain barrier and
other things that they're adding to
these mixtures not all of them there's
different sets of goop that they dump on
us but they are putting uh MN a
messenger your ribonucleic acid now if
you don't know what that is that's a
stranded DNA that they're using aids to
connect to your body through gain a
function so they can control and read
your thoughts and
bodies and they say we won't ever need
an election because they'll know what
our answer is already through Ai and
that is the interface that they are
dumping in the clouds so with that being
said I don't think I have to elaborate
on how legal or unlegal it is you're
going along with
genocide they're poisoning our crops the
aluminum makes it so crops don't absorb
water unless you they have a patent on a
specific type of seed in California and
if you buy their seed your stuff will
grow me as a farmer I've already noticed
the difference last year in the size of
our crops their seed versus our heirloom
which is always worked in gilmington
it's different now already and I watch
these planes leave from Portland and
they drive straight down the Gil the the
lowen ridge headed straight to Vermont
you watch them dump it out in the same
flight pattern every time and they are
blasting it with radio waves CU you can
see the waves in the clouds as they
light them up the way this works is it
heats up the Nano particles that like
the aluminum that is in there and that
heat creates a thinner place in the
atmosphere and that stalls weather or
makes it go around they literally move
rainstorms to or from places you say
it's dry out it's cuz they made it dry
it's not raining it's not cuz there's no
water up there it's because they moved
it around you and harp uses a barge that
floats this gigantic trillion watt laser
out around and they are off your coast
and they shoot it from anywhere on Earth
they want to float these things it's not
just the infrastructure that's in Alaska
it's not just the one that's down in
Puerto Rico it's not just the one up in
Norway it's not the one in Germany we
have them floating around the world
blasting our atmosphere I ran for
governor last year and I came in third
in the Republican primary and this is
one of the legs of the stool I went on
this getting rid of voting machines and
stop poisoning us unv voluntarily with
these mandated vaccines that are poison
poison folks and this stuff in the air
is the same stuff that's in the vaccine
in some of these Blends so you are not
doing it willingly but by not making
laws against it you're complicit so
thank you for your time if anybody has a
question I'd be happy to answer
anybody all right thank you very much
for hearing my reality thank you next up
is Bob
mccl who um is from Grant grout Hill or
grill
how are you
doing we're good how are you goad thank
you for having me
Representatives I got a couple things to
add as
well um HB 1700 when Jason put that
through last year I believe maybe you
guys don't really know but it went viral
across social media across the country
people are making videos about it they
were super excited for it to be going
through and everybody was looking
towards New Hampshire as you know you
guys are doing that I like it you know
and uh it felt good to see that in New
Hampshire and all these people making
the videos but jumping on top of that
it's going to be a big deal when it
comes down to all this because what
Kelly was talking about earlier
obviously we're going through a lot
of uh executive orders and they're going
ping ping ping and nobody knows what's
going to happen and they're like the
most wackiest things you know like uh
getting rid of paper straws if who knew
that was going to be an executive order
but it was and I'm going to tell you
right now we are in a Big Clock Earth is
a part of it the sun is the center of it
and there's planets flying all over and
if you guys paid attention a little bit
you notice that there was a bunch of
planets that lined up over the
last actually they're still lined up and
these planets are all made out of
different materials and they all Vibe at
different Vibes Metals gases rocks we're
in a big Cosmic clock and uh we we're
supposed to be vibing with these big
Celestial planets but how would you stop
that maybe spray the skies with
different metals and hit them with
frequencies like 5G might sound a little
wacky but when you get down to it you
realize that everything's vibrational
uh on top of this I just want to say uh
I'm sick of these hazy sunsets in the
summertime I lay out in the sun by the
water quite a bit and uh I pay attention
to the Sun and I pay attention to all
the clouds and I'm sick of it I know
everybody's sick of it and it's not like
you guys can stop them from doing it and
probably are like what is that even
talking about but you know what really
it's like a big Collective and like he
Kelly was talking about the executive
orders are going to start coming through
who knows if there's going to be one for
that but like I said I used I always lay
out in the sun all the time and I
noticed during the Trump presidency that
there was less Chemtrails during that
time than there is during the Biden
more nope that's
it oh wait one more we've been finding
that in Alzheimer's patients there's
massive amounts of aluminum deposits in
these brains and it's messing with the
neurons and if they're spraying aluminum
down and everybody's breathing it in
it's like the best way to intake it
maybe any
questions
questions apparently not that's thank
okay next up we'll call on
wheeler welcome representative to
st& thank you chairman Vos members and
Friends of the Science Tech house at
Science and Technology committe I don't
often come here cuz I don't have a PhD
so I just uh try to leave this to you
guys now people when they first hear
about this they say oh my God what a
conspiracy theory what a crazy crackpot
ridiculous conversation I don't even
know why I'm here but then you actually
take the time to do the research not on
infowars.com but just on the government
websites and what information is
available to to the public right now and
it's clear that our skies are being
poisoned and I'm here not as somebody
who knows why or knows what's going on
but somebody just to say we should
address this the state should actually
take the time to address this if it is
going on I'm positive it's illegal
because nobody voted on it and I think
that RSA 12K should be repealed I think
that
12f thank you so many numbers 12f should
be
repealed and I think that we should
clean up our skies so that they can be
blue skies again um you know there's a
lot of pollution going on in this world
and I think that if we were to move
forward with cloud seeding or any of the
other
um programs or projects that people who
have a lot of wealth and a lot of money
would like to move forward on then we
leave ourselves in a dangerous position
so I would urge the members of the
science technology committee to look in
to this and to continue to do what they
can to potentially repeal 12f and to
address some of these other uh concerns
in here and I would also say to look
into the concerns around radiation uh
from the Wi-Fi bands and 5G Technologies
everyone says oh that's a crackpots
conspiracy theory but again you look
into it the Wi-Fi radiation bands they
do have an effect on people and the more
that we're allowing these Wi-Fi bands to
go unregulated unaffected by the
government the more we're putting our
people at harm uh I'm here because I I
have a military family I grew up under
the
strong character of somebody who I won't
say his name because he'd be upset if I
did in a public space but he was special
ops and he is
um uh that's all I'll say that's all I
can say I suppose but let me just say
let me just say this is something that
should be looked into into much more and
you don't need a 21-year-old or crazy
conspiracy theorists to tell you that
you can look into a number of the other
public well documented official records
that exist of of this going on this has
been something that has been posited
since the early
1930s uh and it's a practice that has
been employed since that time so I thank
the committee for the time I have to get
back to committee as Kelly knows you
know
where are where's Kelly but I thank you
the committee for its time and I I hope
that we'll be able to find something out
on on this level thank you uh we always
enjoy an opportunity to spend some time
with you Jonah so thank you for
coming all right he's got to get back to
committee so we'll move on
and I'm going to call up another speaker
but I'm going to apologize ahead of time
for not being able to totally
decipher the the name I think it's Ro
iar does that sound like somebody who's
here Rea starts with r starts with an r
first name is our last name is e or
maybe F and you filled out a pink card
so that should narrow it down is it Rosa
no just for the record could you could
you could you spell out your name for me
so I
can press the button please thank you
Risa R IA Evans EV ANS OHA Evans okay so
um thank you to the committee for um
considering ing this issue which I do
think is one of the most important
issues of our time and to representative
Penza for coming back with a wonderful
bill this year um I wasn't planning to
testify but the discussion about RSA 12f
just made me want to say a couple of
things about that so 12 F1 so I think
one of the things that's really
important in this statute um that allows
weather modification is that there is
absolutely no requirement of any risk
benefit analysis there's no requirement
that there be any benefits at all indeed
let alone a requirement that the
benefits outweigh the risks and so you
know RSA 12 F1 really leaves us as
sitting ducks in New Hampshire so that's
just I think the absence of any cost
benefit requirement of a cost benefit
analysis or benefit is just reason alone
to to you know repeal that Statute in
the section of the um amended um HB 764
that does allowed um CL seating in the
cases of an emergency a drought there's
a requirement that the that the state
make a finding you know that there will
not be harm to they have to assess the
potential risks and benefits and ensure
that the activities will not result in
harm to the environment so there's a
clear Improvement in terms of the
activities that are allowed in the you
know in the in the proposed bill so so I
just wanted to talk because I think
there was some discussion before about
you know what are what are the
differences and I think you know the
other difference of course is that the
the existing statute allows us to be
experimented on without without any
consent and the activities that are
allowed in the in the proposed Bill are
just in case of emergency when you know
when there's a finding that those
activities will benefit the people of
New Hampshire and also not harm the
environment so um so then stepping aside
from the statutes I just want to follow
up on what um several people have
testified to about the importance of
looking up at our skies really with an
open mind with curiosity and with
honesty um I have been watching the
skies with dismay for over 10 years
really not wanting to believe what I
have seen I can remember and some of you
on this committee are old enough to
remember this too lying on my back on
the beach looking up into a deep blue
sky and seeing those billowy cumulus
clouds that are so beautifully defined
you know they're just like like these
these these things you just you on
unbelievably beautiful and specific and
clear so you look up at the sky now and
try to try to remember the last time
that there was a crystal clear blue day
with a few really well-defined clouds
that behaved the way clouds behave the
way they're supposed to behave you just
you have to look up and another another
sign that you're seeing a geoengineered
sky is that the clouds don't behave the
way that real clouds behave real clouds
are orderly they float on air currents
they they they just have an order in
them which is why so many artists have
painted them but if you look at the
skies now they're what I call chimeras
they're just clouds going in every
direction because they weren't put there
by Nature they're not natural so it
really is happening as hard as it is to
accept um so you have an opportunity to
do something about this and I really
urge you to take it up because this is
really a you know a a a historic
opportunity thank
Raa seeing none thank you last word on
this legislation goes to Jason
Gard who I believe was the author of the
bill that we heard last year so welcome
back uh The Honorable Jason geard uh
thank you but I I wish there was a poliy
you could choose if you have the
honorable title or not I just find that
kind of weird nobility kind of thing but
I appreciate that not no offense to um
Jason Gart out of norfield and I just
wanted to come in today I left work
that's so I'm kind of dressed as I am
but I work outside so I build houses up
on Squam Lake and winaki and it's very
beautiful up there I think it's nice
being up in the
mountains and I'm outside all day long I
mean that's what I'm I'm on a roof or
doing whatever so I have I don't want to
tr say that my personal experience is
greater than your expertise everybody in
the room is definitely smarter than I am
but at the same time when you see
these CL these condensation Trails
coming out of these airplanes that
behave differently as the much better
verse speaker before me
mentioned you you're required to believe
essentially the government bureaucrats
and as we found out through recent uh
recent releases through the whole Doge
thing paid you know media sources on the
narrative that we're currently
experiencing and I just find that highly
problematic in the fact that we have
these commit these committees set up
through the state house and as a state
representative you are the oversight for
the rest of the government but also
you're a check on the federal government
we're not just supposed to be we Sorry
formerly but it's not just a rubber
stamp kind of a gig this is actually a
pretty serious Endeavor and I just think
when you have this many people who are
willing to take off their time from work
living so forth and I understand you
guys are here but that's a different
story you get $100 but we need to really
take seriously and and wonder what's
going on and is it worth my time to and
as I can say at least for myself and
many people here if any one of you on
the committee said I want some evidence
on this this and this or I want you to
show me people would bend over backwards
we got a guy will to give out blood
samples which sound a little crazy but I
mean it's it's it's really it's really
indicative of the way that New Hampshire
is where people care about each other
and I think that's what this comes down
to we had the government tell just
sidetrack I'm coming back we had the
government tell us that fluide was the
best thing ever now we know it's
basically retarding children's
educational opportunities I mean that's
a serious thing and it took a long time
and I know multiple bills came through
and got shot down in that period of time
not blaming you guys but just saying
that I I just worry where we're on this
hole well we'll wait till we know for
sure that this is going on I mean we
have operation large area coverage in
1957-58 by the US Army chemical Corps
they involved spraying large areas from
Wikipedia zinc cadum sulfide over cities
including St Louis got hit really bad
there's some it came out in the news
around decade ago they were looking into
it again and they're saying if it's
radioactive as well but the point being
is we have a government that will
experiment on us it's it's basically a
fact at this point so I believe that you
as another element of government but
closer to me should investigate this
seriously reach out to people who were
much smarter than I am and maybe even
smarter than the people in his room and
find out what's going on because we
really we're suffering here we're
suffering here and I think people are
actually literally dying from storms
that are being manipulated we can talk
about project Cirrus back in the 50s
where they seated a hurricane off the
coast of North Carolina well it was in
North Carolina anyway made a hook back
into Mainland caused a bunch of damage
and death Army denied it for a long time
finally admitted it and yeah we're just
we getting into a weird place I just
wanted two quotes I'll read and then
I'll leave you guys alone this is from
President John F Kennedy addressing the
United Nations in 1961 we shall propose
further Cooperative efforts between all
nations in weather prediction and
eventually in weather control
1961 they just haven't been sitting
around we as you see we waste billions
of dollars on crazy things so second
quote is it lays the predicate and
foundation for the development of a
weather satellite that will permit man
to determine the world's Cloud layer and
ultimately to control the weather and he
who controls the weather will control
the world that was Lyndon Baines Johnson
at Southwest Texas State Texas State
University in 1962 and if you guys get a
chance that video clip is really crazy
the way he has this really kind of Dr
Evil thing going on it's really creepy
so anyway um I want to thank you for
your time and I really would encourage
anybody if you if you want to reach out
to anybody here I know most of people
here you can contact me or them directly
and let's just look into this seriously
Tennessee made a step in the right
direction I disagree with Kelly on this
I think there should be a penalty
provision even if it's $1 and I kind of
get the concept if you put a penalty
provision in and you establish liability
the lawsuits the lawsuits will start
flooding in but that's the point courts
are how we're supposed to handle our
problems not through mobs in the street
and so forth we should litigate these
things take experts from both sides and
figure out what's going on and I think
that's what this really comes down to in
a lot of ways is nobody wants to be
caught liable for the harm so thank you
well thank you and I apologize for
calling you honorable but I appreciate
that I didn't intend to insult you by
doing that so no questions I guess for
Mr Gard well that being the last pink
card that I have I think this uh public
hearing is now complete so I will can I
say one thing real quick yes
representative Potenza will allow you to
come back and just real quick be real
quick thank you okay so I just wanted to
to follow up on the speaker that came in
um uh from The Business Association so
when so in the original bill of 764
before I pulled out um they used um they
used the HB 1700 from last session they
used that in the description so even in
the original bill of 764 it didn't have
anything about um microwave radiation or
any of that so um so and she realized
that she screwed up but she said okay
well you're you're most likely going to
do an amendment so I never changed the
description um and of course everything
came as we all know when we were Bill
filing so um in the previous version it
never it never talks about you know
electromagnetic radio frency or
microwave radiation in in the original
bill either so that was a mistake from
OS they just pulled the exact same
description from U from HP 1700 I just
wanted the committee to know that and
I'm glad the speaker said we're all good
with the bill or you know no position so
that's really good um I just wanted to
make that a note so so you're saying
that the title of the bill the title of
the bill in the amendment is now fixed
but before when it came out it that was
from that's the exact same um yeah she
didn't grab my title she put everything
else in but she told she pulled the
title from the bill from HP 1700 so
that's why of course that other speaker
when they were going to oppose it was
con you know was concerned because it
was just in the title but it wasn't
there wasn't anything in the bill that
talked about it anyway so so the
scheduling notice that we had for
today's public hearings had two titles
that were incorrect due to something
that OS did correct well okay good
thank
you all right with that we'll close the
public hearing on House Bill
764 FN and that will conclude unless
there are uh activities the committee
would like to conduct representative
PL uh thank you chair there was a
request for the
online um
testimony I'll start with the blue sheet
uh that's what we've been doing
H
Bill House Bill
696 three in favor none
opposed House Bill
708 there was no comment either way 0
Z
hcr2 two in favor one
opposed house bills
House Bill
764 four in favor one
opposed the
online uh same order House Bill
696 12 in favor five
opposed HB
708 two in favor two to
AOS
HRC two
there was nine in favor 13
opposed HB
710 six in favor 14 oppos HB
28 in favor 10
opposed thank you chair okay thank you
representative
PL does anybody else have anything to uh
bring to our attention today
okay we're done thank you very much
we'll see you all in session on Thursday
and the committee will meet again next
week on Tuesday not on Monday because
Monday is a
holiday so we'll see you Thursday take
care